All Hutch has to do is admit that he likes snarking. He's a snarker.
He loves snarking on Hassan. How do you disconnect the fact that
you make way more money by ragging on Hassan than you do for
your political takes? That like your political takes don't really
have a market, but they're writing on Hassan has a market and
you make a lot of money from that. He's a weird, hateful creep
who loves snarking on Hassan, who loves spending his time stalking
Hassan. How do you disconnect that and make a dispassionate analysis
this situation and figure out what's actually good for people
versus just good for you?
>> I'll just catch you guys up real quick. Okay, [music]
there was a tweet. I lied actually. I just lied to you guys.
I do have these tweets. I did grab these. I didn't do nothing.
But basically, Hassan tweeted about there's some somebody had
a property of a lost shirt on or may maybe they did, maybe they
didn't. Hassan says, "Come on, man." Hutch says, "Alex Jones
level conspiracy theory nonsense is not a problem. Exclusive
to the to manga on the right." Lyen responds, "Hey, just curious.
Are the next few weeks slmon months, depending on the length
of conflict, going to be mostly dedicated to useless Assan coverage,
or do you plan to try to do something important on this issue?"
And Hutch says, Hutch says, "What the LOL friend? If you don't
like the stuff I post, unfollow/muteblock
me."
[laughter] This is kind of funny. It's a nice copout response.
It'd be way more honest to say that you like the bene the positive
benefits it brings your channels and you value that more than
meaningful substantive content. You're not saving America by
dunking on Hassan to an audience that already hates Hassan. Well,
that sounds pretty obvious, right? Pretty obvious, right? Now,
all Hutch I've said this multiple times.
Multiple times. All Hutch has to do is admit that he likes snarking.
He's a snarker. He loves snarking on Hassan. He's a weird, hateful
creep who loves snarking on Hassan. Who loves spending his time
stalking Hassan who okay that he just has to make some admissions.
If he can admit these things,
then welcome to the team Hutch. Okay, welcome to the team Hutch.
Welcome to the Okay, he could be my my snarking brother. Okay,
but that he has to admit he's not a political actor in any way.
Just admit it. Admit it, Hutch. Admit it. Admit it. Admit it.
Admit it. Admit it. Admit it. Admit it. Admit it. Admit it. Just
admit it. Just admit it. Just admit it. Just admit it. Just admit
it. You're not a political analyst. You're not a political actor.
You're just a starker. Which is fine. Which is fine. But just
admit it. Okay. Just admit it.
Okay. So, there's this little exchange and then eventually Hutch
hops on. I'll probably cover more tweets there cuz I think Hutch
started responding to like substance and too.
But for now, that catches you up enough so that we can start
this conversation. Okay. Okay. And we do want to start catching
up. So >> So what what uh what what in particular brought
you in here?
>> Well, you've hit me up a few times now. So you seem
to have an issue with uh
I don't even know if you have an issue with the particulars of
what I say a lot of the times. It's just it's more that you think
that uh >> Well, hold on. I So right off the bat on this
tweet,
I feel like Hassan's saying, "Come on, man." because it's like
people running with this narrative.
Is this really is it really just come on man is the like this
is a false flag, these are crisis actors moment or was Hassan
doing it on stream a bunch and so it's like a continuation of
that cuz maybe if he was like saying on stream that it was a
false flag and he didn't believe it. But like come on man like
that could actually mean to call that Alex Jones levels of conspiracy
theory nonsense. I know for a fact this bald knows Hassan is
a property of a law hoodie. Maybe maybe there's a tweet from
the previous day.
Okay. Well, I I that's why I just to know if I'd have a problem
with this or not, I would probably have to see what else Han
has said. Uh yes, Hassan is signaling that it's fake because
of his past tweet to give plausible deniability. Okay. Yeah,
that's that's why. Hey, never say I'm not fair. I said I'd have
to see more cuz like just this in a vacuum alone seems like it'd
be crazy to say this. So I I waited. I waited and keep going.
>> But I that my time would be better spent
talking about different things.
>> It uh >> so you know >> Yeah. It's um I
said this at the beginning of the the stream cuz someone asked
me like you know asked me about this and it's like when you started
getting into politics I was like oh here's a a dude who's like
earnestly cons like you know involved. He's a liberal. he's um
he is like, you know, there's a lot of sincerity to it. And I
think there's a lack of sincerity to the the degree to which
you cover both Hassan and the right. And like I I I try to make
this very clear like I'm no fan of Hassan. Uh you know, people
want to call me a leftist, whatever. I don't give a at the end
of the day. I'm not though. And so they're wasting their time
barking up the wrong tree. Um I I have my huge grievances with
the but like I don't think the levels
he's covered is proportional to his impact. He's huge. He's big.
There are a lot of people out there that watch him. But I also
think that um I think I brought this up in one of our recent
Twitter uh interactions was that, you know, we need these people's
votes. We do. Maybe not Hassan himself, but we need his audience.
We're not going to get those people to come out and vote. He
is someone that could genuinely mobilize a lot of people to vote.
And we're not going to [__] get that if it's just,
you know, uh team sports. That's not going to >> No. Hutch.
Oh, Lyan doesn't get it. You don't need them. You don't need
them.
They're not liberals. They're not strong liberals. They're not
committed, principled liberals. You don't need them. You need
people like Counterpoints. Who would vote for JD Vance over Wait,
who is it? JD Vance over AOC. You need principled committed liberals
like Counterpoints. Okay, that's what you need. I have an issue
with like the frequency of the coverage because once it starts
veering into
>> um disproportionate levels compared to what we're actually
trying to achieve, then I think it's just all about show and
I I I've grown past that. I don't like that [__]
anymore. Like I don't like the the the team sport games and all
that crap. I I care too much about what's going on and it I don't
have the brain capacity to like really be tolerant of like that
waste. So, if people want to be entertainers, fine. But something
I said earlier is that like I'm if if if people do that, then
I'm going to view you more as an entertainer than a serious political
commentator. And to that end, I'm then going to feel more freedom
to devalue certain comments such as the US aid comments when
um when it's like, yeah, but we'll go spend another week months
after it happened on the the shot caller thing. So like yeah,
I do have a problem with the like degree to which you cover it
because you talk with such sincerity about things like the fascistic
threat to the country, but then we'll go just everything about
Hassan, Hassan, Hassan. And it's like they're much more important
things. I brought up on the Wick panel that one time that I I
jumped in for a comment. I brought up that like, hey, you know,
people want to be are are pointing out like the violence, you
know, quote unquote, or the rioters, you know, in the >> I
wouldn't even I I like super don't care about Hutch covering
Hassan when it's important. Like this specific tweet is probably
not where I would make this stand, right? But it it it is more
like, okay, this is a this is like the straw that broke the camel's
back on this one, right? It's not it's not really about this
tweet. It's about Hutch doing this super consistently. the LA
riots and it's like why the are we putting any breath towards
that when the United States president just uh you know unilaterally
send in National Guard troops um to go to these cities and shut
down the these protests? Like why are we focusing on the few
acts of violence and and uh uh what's the term? Not sabotage
um and uh uh vandalism and whatnot. Why are we in any way, shape,
or form helping the Trump administration out by wasting our breath
on the left on that when at the end of the day, the important
thing is that the president sent troops to quell protests.
I I think it's a waste of time and it helps them just like when
Steven Miller comes out and he starts calling the left, you know,
commies and then people on the left want to go, "Yeah, yeah,
those commies right there." And it's like, "No, no, Stephen Miller
means all of you, right? So why even give deference to that?
All it does is help them." I I it's my my issues with the like
online politics commentary are are
Well, I mean, if you had to >> Dude, I know Hutch wasn't
listening. I already know Hutch wasn't listening. I know he's
about to just restate his general premise about why he covers
Asan. I know there's just no shot that he was listening at all
right there. And he is actually just gonna restate why he covers
Assassan without responding category like to anything Lyan just
said. I feel I just feel it in my bones. I I want to be wrong.
I want to be wrong. Okay. I want to be wrong here. >> Guess
yourself.
Like make the strongest possible argument that I would make as
to why I spend time talking about those people and these things.
Like what what would you come up with? I mean, I was not being
a smartass when I said I think at the end of the day, you you've
um you've gone from like the serious political commentary route
to the, you know, the online pundit route and now you are >> Well,
I know that's your take. I I understand that. But I'm I'm asking
you
to put yourself
in my shoes. And even >> that's not how you start. I It
is steel me. He's saying steal me. I know.
It's just like it's so lazy. like just respond to the things
he said
which what your response should be is something along the lines
of like yeah I do do that but I think it's important do you know
what like I agree with your criticism that I cover Hassan a lot
probably disproportionately to what's actually like the worst
things in the country but do you think there's a reason I do
that like there's there's ways to navigate this conversation
that makes sense and don't just
I don't know how many times I have to watch this guy like not
really care about what someone's saying and sort of just like
totally terminate their question or or some commentary they're
making to just give his own thing. >> Even if you don't
believe it's true, like give me the steel man argument for
>> if I were to steal it, I would say
>> don't that you think that these people are um that these
people pose a threat to
um liberal democracy and to success against Donald Trump. >> Um
hold on, Moody Morgan, you'd be shocked at how much streamers
because I know this happens to me, right? Like when I have a
couple people from like Hassan's audience, I'll get inundated
with like examples of how Hassan's like not that bad, right?
Like basically people make criticisms and I'll get like a lot
of clips showing me like why those clips or why some commentary
might be wrong. I'm sure the converse is true for Hutch where
he is getting like a lot of clips from people who are in communities
who really hate Hassan who are going to consistently show him
the worst elements of Hassan so that he can further hate Hassan,
right? It's like actually audience capture in a very very explicit
>> and those like Trump and that you spend all of the time
that you do on them because you think that is the uh that that
kind of push back is going to have material benefits for the
Democratic party in the long run.
Um, I mean, yeah, that's one way to put it, I suppose. But
I like my politics right now at this point in my life are less
about specific policies and more about just
addressing the current situation as it is and doing a bit of
triage and like figuring out, you know, what what is the biggest
threat right now. And uh I've thought for a really long time
that the Republican party has just become so rotten and corrupt
that
um we have to ruthlessly beat them in every election where that's
possible. And so like my politics more succinctly in the current
moment are just like I hate Republicans and I want them to like
lose elections. And um I think would you agree that the alternative
media space especially after 2024
has by the way
you can make this argument really easily as Hutch right you just
make the argument like I have a niche I think it helps and I
think when I look at the total landscape nobody else is doing
this niche now that's a total lie but it's at least some argument
some justification for your behavior like he would have to argue
there are not enough people talking about how bad Hassan is for
Democrats. So, I think like I feel the need there. I'm like in
a niche that's important. Unfortunately, he has to deal with
the fact that there are literally like
millions of views almost at millions of views a week
if I want to say a day, but probably a week I'll say on the Hassan's
bad stuff. Right. So, so it's like there's no there's an excess
supply there to be honest with you. as identified by Nicholas
Dioro. Nicholas Dioro sees that there's an excess supply low
lower demand right on the Hassan's bad stuff. He immediately
pivots away. >> Definitely kind of veered into a new kind
of importance in terms of like the national conversation, the
zeitgeist. >> I I I'd say I I felt that way since 2020.
Um I think the uh even if it's it's not as much as it was, but
I think that started in 2020. I'd agree with
Yeah, I think it started going way back even to like 2008, but
but I I would say that in 2024 for me, and I don't really have
like an empirical basis to make this claim. It's just more kind
of vibes and just gut feeling, but it felt like 2024
was really the beginning of
like an like a new official paradigm where alternative media,
I think, is arguably more important than traditional media now.
Um, I thought that calls from people like Jenk in 2016, you know,
back like 10 years ago saying we've we've replaced mainstream
media is like I always thought that those were kind of cringe
and it's not like alternative media didn't matter, but it wasn't
there yet. But I do think we we have crossed that point where
social media algorithms and uh political content creators probably
have more sway on the public than like traditional channels like
CNN >> Oh, I Fox News. >> I don't disagree at all.
I think um hell even if I talked to my mom who is still an ardent
Republican and someone who defends says she hates Trump but yet
will defend everything he's does. Um except sidebar like yesterday
she called me and said I had my bridge too far moment. It was
the AI weapons thing was her her one moment but either way. Yeah.
Like she tells me like I don't watch Fox News but I know where
she's getting her [__] from and it's from it was
from Charlie Turk and Facebook and all that stuff. Yeah. So no
I I don't disagree but something you said was you know that you
want to you you said something about triage. We're talking about
the um the Republican party being just this demonic [__]
entity which it is. Um >> yeah, I think it means that you
can't really afford to be
super picky when it comes to policy. So then what what I don't
one I think big example of this is like I did not understand
you and I's push back to Rashad because Rashad like from the
get-go from the beginning you said well who is your champ after
he gave some heat for Newsome he was like okay well who's your
champion he says [__] Camala Harris he doesn't say
AOC or Bernie or anyone like that he says Kamala Harris right
that is not like you're super you know super progressive or lefty
even um Democrat and like his point that he was making was okay
Trump bad has gotten us this far and he gave difference to you
guys and said, "Yes, these election wins are great, but he's
saying that we have to think long term because one day Trump
will be gone, hopefully, inshallah." Uh, and Trump is gone. Trumpism
doesn't leave. The Republican party isn't suddenly healed. We
still have to deal with this threat. And if our messaging consistently
relies on Trump bad, like the the the most Trump bad election
that I've seen was 2024 with comma. But even even then, she did
talk quite a bit about, you know, things other than Trump. But,
you know, I don't think 2020 was a Trump bad election. I don't
think 2018 was a Trump bad blue wave. That was an election that
was focused on healthcare. 2020 was an election that was focused
on um instability and chaos for for the uh for for from COVID
and like you know wanting wanting a competent administration
to you know help the coordinate with the states to get the vaccine
out and >> where was this that night because that night
you and I just pushed back on him for having any sort of heat
where his ultimate point was hey I don't I'm not seeing from
Newsome the kind of heat we need for Republicans and I'm also
not seeing the messaging that says hey we are the Democratic
party and he explicitly said this he's like I'm not seeing the
messaging that says we are the Democratic party we're going to
give you X Y and Z this is why you should come and be a part
of our party. This is why he's not vote. Like, it was it was
immediate hostility to the fact that he was like, I don't think
Nome's the dude. >> No, no, no, no. Hang on. I didn't say
I I don't think Nome's the dude. That wasn't my problem with
Rashad.
>> No, was it? Because it like the whole thing about the
Supreme Court didn't happen until an hour into that conversation.
So, it was like consistent push back on him for saying, "Yeah,
I don't like the way that he engaged with Ben Shapiro. I don't
like what I'm seeing from him. I'm not >> There was push
back on just the idea that Democrats weren't running effectively,
right? Lyen is talking
basically when Rashad is saying we need like a broader appeal.
We need some like long-term strategy of sorts like some kind
of long-term strategy. Hutch and and Ira were both pushing back
and saying we just we're we we went up we were up 15 with like
this election. We're we're pulling plus 15 over here, right?
We're winning in the polls right now. seeing the the kind of
and you brought up a worry which is a worry that I have is that
whoever we end up nominating like if they're the most palatable
someone who's going to get you know enough people excited to
vote um someone that can stand up to you know Vance or whoever
is the successor to Trump um my concern is that like they're
going to come in and they're going to have no heat for undoing
what's happened and that's like a longer discussion because that's
like one of those something I've been toying with is I don't
know how we recover without violence and I don't want violence
but I also don't want someone that just comes in and tries to
pretend that didn't happen like we did in 2020 and then Trump
never gets [__] prosecuted. I mean to be clear I
mean Biden did that. Biden got really aggressive early on in
his administ. >> No he did not. He did not get anywhere
near aggressive. >> He reversed most are like most >> Oh
not on policy. It's not the policy stuff. Hutch.
People need to understand that the corruption that's occurred
under this government will never happen again in the entire history
of your country.
Like people need to be
it needs to actually be buo. Okay. That's the thing.
The punishment needs to be biblical for the people who have tried
to loot your country like this. It needs to be unquestionable.
You never do this. This is the one. This is like essentially
Dude, I I don't even know. Like at least double agent spies have
loyalty to another country. This is like loyalty to yourself.
This is like the worst of the worst. Like I can't fathom these
kinds of people. >> Yeah. the vast majority of Trump's
executive orders were reversed in the first like two months.
>> That's fine. I'm talking about those who have like the
real attacks on on the constitution like the people responsible
for them. Like I want to see heads roll for a lot of this that's
happened. Metaphorically of course. Well, I feel like we're veering
away from the point. Like my issue with >> only metaphor
was that he started to veer into territory that I just find to
be kind of cringe and lar.
>> By the way, I don't think like for general Republicans,
I don't even think for like state reps, I think there's like
a handful of people in your federal government who have have
like basically come together to try to enrich themselves by tens
of billions of dollars. Those are the people. Okay, it's just
them. Let's hold off before that cuz I we can go into that. But
like that didn't happen for like an hour or so into the conversation.
It was immediate. Like we can pull it up. Within the first 5
minutes of him saying he doesn't like Newsome, like the the response
to it is as if he was hanging. >> Hang on. But wait, hang
on. >> Guess what? Guess what? We've actually figured out
the the time where the Seal Team Six hypothetical works and it
is in the interest of the country and I can defend it as a presidential
act. Okay? So, make sure you guys elect a Democrat next time,
please, for the love of God. Was my push back you shouldn't criticize
Newsome or did I have an issue with his specific push back? >> Uh
it was the his specific push back but the read to me is like
that there is no push back that's tolerable to Newsome. There
was I saw no difference or IRI to like any of his criticism.
Well, I mean, you'd have we'd have to address each criticism
one by one, right? Like I I don't even Which criticism which
criticism do you think that I wasn't giving enough deference
to or giving enough good faith to? So when he when he says that
the uh he says that the the party or sorry he gives his push
back about um he says like uh you know him being buddy buddy
with Shapiro about the violin stuff and uh you know that kind
of like engagement makes him uncomfortable and doesn't make him
feel that he's going to see the right kind of gumption from him
when he if he were to take office or if he were to go toe-to-toe
with the Vance that he's not going to to have the right heat
for these people or that he's courting the wrong ideas.
>> I see ogre boy like is that I think it is childish juvenile
really myopic to like judge a politician based on podcast appearances
over like what they've done throughout the totality of their
career and what they've done more recently uh in the last 6 years
as governor of California like he has someone extensive track
record of um going to bad for trans people in the state in ways
that go way beyond
every other state >> and he never undermined that on that
on at appearance and someone who is able to be governor isn't
necessarily able to be the the you know especially here's the
thing like he's also a governor in a blue state right like a
very hardcore blue state and so his ability to push this these
policies and to to go toe-to-toe with the Republicans that he
has to deal with in his region it's completely different than
like the national stage and getting people that >> No,
I I understand like I agree he is not I would pick three other
candidates four maybe five other candidates before I picked him
to be the nominee because I agree like I don't number one I don't
know if he has enough broad appeal to win a national race like
the presidency. And number two, uh, you know, >> um, I
don't know if this is Lykan's criticism. Lyken is repeating,
I believe, Rashad's criticism here. >> I don't know if
he, you know, he hasn't shown to me yet that he is capable of
forging the kind of consensus that you need to get major bills
done. So, I have my concerns about Newsome, too. That's not the
issue. The issue is the specific criticisms that he was making
I thought were kind of silly. And like the idea that
Well, >> yeah. Yeah. I mean, the idea that Newsome has
[clears throat] like abandoned trans people or is signaling that
he would abandon trans people is preposterous. It is actually
preposterous. It is so stupid.
>> Uh I to be honest with you, bro, I don't even remember
what the [__]
[laughter]
>> Wait, Hutch. Hutch, can you tell me who suggested that?
Hey, Hutch, can you tell me who said that? Is there something
occupying your mind currently that's from a different person?
And who is that different person? who said something about Newsome
abandoning trans people. I
>> cuz I I I was listening like contrary to what people
think I'm very good faith and so I I like one of the things I
walked back cuz when I first listened to this I was I was on
Rashad's side completely and I was like yeah Newsome playing
footsie with Shapiro I don't like that but then I listened again
when I reacted on stream and uh you guys you were IRI brought
up that like or maybe it was so brought up that he had push back
on other areas and I was like you know what there's nothing wrong
with building rapport and talking about violins or whatever the
[__] it was to get your you know ideological opponent
into a position where they're going to be more immunable to engaging
with you and no problem that. So, I'm willing to walk that [__]
back, but then I go watch a few other clips and I'm like, man,
I don't know. I think I think Newsome may have flubbed some areas
uh when it comes to this. So, I I am fully >> But so do
I, though. I mean, but again,
>> like it. I feel the same way. Like, I didn't like a
couple of his responses. But when you listen to the entire podcast,
it is clear that he is like pushing back like 99% of the time,
>> right? But what I'm saying is like if he if he um if
Rashad uh you know implied in any way that Newsome would abandon
you know trans people until I see something that would make me
agree with that. No I I know what 14 different bills uh he has
passed that have uh been beneficial to trans people in in the
state of California. Don't I'm all for that. But I didn't hear
anything that made me think that that was his criticism. Like
I was I was listening for what his criticism was that made everyone
so hostile towards him. And it didn't get to the Supreme Court
again until like an hour and a half in.
Um, again, I would I would have to go back and listen to that
podcast because I don't I don't remember like what kicked out.
>> I'd be down for that now and you know, I've got time.
So, I'll listen to it again and I'll come to you. You know, I'll
ping you and we can we can chat >> Well, now I'm curious.
Hold on.
>> Now, I want to look it up here. I'm just going to do
a transcript and look up Newsome and see what the first
>> source of content. >> My thing is about Newsome.
My my criticism would be on on the long-term strategy point and
Hutch and I essentially like advocating for complacency, advocating
for what we're doing now is working. And and I think Rashad's
point back was not really contended with at all from what I remember,
right? Like they they did not want to engage with it. They just
said, "Well, guys, what we're doing is working. We're up plus
15 right now. >> I'm 20 minutes." Even in response to when
when Rashad said, "Yeah, I know we're up, but like my concern
is, you know, it's the Trump effect and he might not be here."
Lying kind of mentioned this, and I don't think we've come up
with like a strategy to to fix it, right? Like we we could just
be in the same problem once once Trump's gone, is JD Vance just
going to step in and it's going to be now we're plus two and
it's like within the margin of error and then we lose another
election.
That's the concern.
>> And and nobody actually talked back. Nobody actually
like engaged with that or at least Hutch definitely didn't. Hutch
just restated, but we're up. I'm saying like Newsome interviewing
Bench >> and he's like, "So tell me about when you learned
how to play the violin." Like what was that like? You're asking
him about playing the violin after 10 years of building up Trump.
That's your question. So, so his initial
and and even reading this I can like find myself going back to
being annoyed.
the I Why do you think I just I'm just curious like why do you
think Nuome is has done a podcast where he's been civil with
extremely far-right individuals >> Well, I already said
that being civil is the best way to actually get them to engage.
If you're not civil, then they're immediately going to shut down
and it's going to be combative in a way that's not going to move
anything forward. If your goal is to ultimately find a way to
connect with their audience, because I don't think anyone believes
they're going to [__] chip Ben Shapiro from the right.
Um, you're ultimately trying to target their audience. Would
you agree with that?
I think uh I don't know if they're Newsome is trying to target
Ben Shapiro's audience. I think that um Newsome is looking at
all the polls that we all can see where that show the electorate
think that the Democratic party are weird and scoldy and uh they
virtue signal too much and they do too much purity testing and
they're too quick to condemn people rather than just kind of
you know treat them with respect and and you know I I think >> by
the way I forgot the Iran war the Iran war here undoes literally
every single argument against US aid. Okay. Every single point
that any of these people ever made against us a Oh,
every time Asiggo's ask about it now, they they're begging for
us to come help them. They're begging. Okay. So, when when the
African mom begs for a malaria vaccine, you're good with giving
that, right? It's way cheaper, actually. Save way more lives
that way. It turns out for way cheaper.
So, that's what that's the US's role. If if somebody's begging
for help, we'll go help them, right? >> I think he's well
aware that the electorate feels that way about um the Democratic
party. And I think that, you know, a strategy of not being um
belligerent in a conversation is probably smart politically right
now. And I I think that's why he's doing it. I think he's addressing
that specific problem in the Democratic party. >> I am
totally for that. Like the whole woke scold and all that stuff.
Like I am I am all for like really >> this is really just
Yeah. Like hold on even less. I'm fine with that. Well, no, no,
no, no, no. You could be fine with it or not. Asmin Gold's not
fine with it. That's the whole point is like he literally will
argue against it. It's not the US's responsibility.
>> Yeah. Exactly. >> That back in. Hell, there are
probably some areas where where you know the woke politics. I'm
I'm okay with like, hey, let's let's maybe en sure that this
vicious threat is gone and get these people like as far away
from like the the anti-trans stuff got so intense that it started
to like backtrack us as a country on like gay rights issues,
right? So, I am I am all for like some semblance of moderation
as long as we're not like losing sight of the major issues. But
again, like when I I listened to this conversation, I didn't
find anything like super objectionable from Rashad. In fact,
I was like eventually he was starting to be treated by like a
leftist. And I'm like, man, this guy is clearly a liberal. Like
unless there's something else out there I haven't seen of like
this dude is like like I don't know a [__] leftist
that is that adamantly like Kamala is my girl. >> He was
advocating for some illiberal stuff, but he's like in terms of
like
>> I guess the leftight spectrum. He's like further to
the center, but he was he was, you know, if you do the the what
the double the the
whatever the the two-dimensional plane that's authoritarianism
versus like leftright economic policy, right? If you do that,
then he was getting increasingly authoritarian in his >> I
I don't know a single one. Again, I'd have to go back and review
the conversation, but like the way that he kicked it out talking
about Newsome. Um, I mean, I I had disagreements with him, but
I don't remember it getting like hostile or anything. I mean,
I don't even feel like it wasn't like screaming shouting match.
It was like that there was like as if this guy was the push back
was so consistent as if this guy was making some insane claims
and he's like his >> Well, he was to be clear. >> Before
we get to the Supreme Court stuff, like he his point, this was
the back and forth for like 30 straight
You hear the condescension again, right?
It's I just wish I wish Hutch had humility like commensurate
with his IQ. It just it's so frustrating listening to somebody
who's so condescending and soing stupid. It's so It's just so
annoying. He is saying again and again, Trump bad ain't enough.
It's got to be something more substantive. It's got to be about
what we're going to do for the people and it's got to be about
addressing the threat. And like one here's one thing I was I
objected to that you said. You're like, you're so adamant about
the Republican party crumbling and I don't know what what makes
you think the Republican party is crumbling to the point that
we are going to be a-ok. Okay. And this guy is saying like be
happy to see the devastation to the Republican party. Be happy
about our electoral wins, but also be prepared because we remember
January 6th happened. You remember all those people that backed
away from Trump and Ma and all that. And then after enough time,
the Republicans realized, hey, like the Republicans, not just
MAGA, the Republicans realized, hey, all we need to do is circle
the wagons, make the failins, and we're fine. We can stand against
anything. And we told them they like we showed them that in 2024
that like the man who was responsible for January 6, all the
people who said [__] Trump for January 6 were right
there back at him because he was their boy and he was getting
into the [__] office. That's what they wanted. That's
what they cared about and that Republic like Lyan's not dumb.
People think Lyan's dumb, but I
somehow somehow you know you massage stuff enough you got like
a big audience who all agrees with one side. Anybody who goes
up against this one commentator apparently comes out looking
stupid. Apparently, apparently, apparently
even when Trump is gone.
>> Again, I I told you that I reject a premise to begin
with. I don't think that Democrats have been in the era of Trump
running solely on Trump bad. And I I have my own criticisms of
the Democratic party. >> Do you not remember that being
part of our discourse? Like us as liberal Democrats, like that
was part of our discourse for like four years was we cannot focus
on Trump bad. And we relied too much on that. We've got to rely
on more than that. >> I I listen I I don't remember ever
saying stuff like this. I mean, of course, I believe this, but
I don't think the Democrats are doing this. The
How are the Democrats doing this? What do you mean? Like, when
I look when I break down like the individual races and I look
at the Democrats that are >> wait, he's saying that that
was the argument back at Rashad, >> you know, winning seats
in New York City and Virginia and New Jersey and >> Lykan
got smarter low key. >> In 2022, we have >> No, no,
like it didn't get smarter. Lean just got closer to the brainwashing
succubus that is straighter. Okay. It's just you can't see the
puppet strings with straight raids in the corner literally puppeteering
like in his really crucial Senate seat races all over the country.
None of them were >> That's obviously I don't believe that.
I literally don't believe that. I don't believe that. Okay. I'm
just That's a joke. It's >> on like Trump bad. They were
all
>> Lykan's always been smart. Lykan has always been a guy
who is he's like smart enough but like nobody in this space is
really like a world beater IQ like some kind of like 145 150
160 IQ that's like solving major problems. You don't engage in
this space is somebody like that. You engage in something where
you could actually make a difference. Okay.
There's nobody like that in this space. Lyken is just somebody
who's like of like pretty far above average IQ. like I I don't
think I'm like significantly more intelligent than like it and
he he puts time into stuff,
right? So, if he's if he's researched into something now, I understand
on the the funny thing is is on the Israel stuff, he couldn't
make the arguments, but he was arguing against one of the better
debaters, like better rhetorical I'm going to make you look dumb.
I'm going to make me look smart debaters in the world. So, I'm
going to like that's that's already a handicap. Okay. And ultimately
the things he was saying like I don't think we trust Israel and
I think here's the evidence for why we can't really trust Israel
to be responsible here. Well, it turns out you actually couldn't
trust Israel to be responsible there. Like to be honest it was
just factually it's in retrospect factually correct that you
could not trust Israel to be responsible in that case.
Right. This guy got c I think you mean coddled in his political
takes. Hutch actually thinks he gives coach takes. Yeah. Sure.
Sure. Sure. >> Crucial Senate seat races all over the country.
None of them were running on like Trump bad. They were all running
on like policy platforms. They were contrasting themselves with
>> kind of like the chaos that comes out of the Republican
party. But I think the Democrats already know that just like
running around doing Trump bad is not good strategy, which is
why they don't do that, >> right? But he's talking about
like we're talking about this fascistic threat and that is becoming
more and more part of the the platform discussions that we're
having. And he's saying that like we can't just talk about that
fascistic threat as if it's just Trump. We have to talk about
that as it's the Republican party and that the >> We can
talk about that with We do though. I mean, I I don't I just don't
>> Yeah, we have those conversations, but our politicians
aren't our politicians aren't out there having the conversation
that like, hey, you're Republican by name. I will call them out
by name. This Republican right here, this person is supporting
this policy, this policy, and this policy that is antithetical
to the American ideal. >> You don't see that happening.
You don't see I mean, like press conferences happening every
day from major Democrats that are calling out Republicans by
It happens every day. Literally every day. If you go on C-SPAN's,
you know, uh, VOD VOD list from last week, that's that's all
they're doing. That's all they've been doing. They're like the
Democratic party right now is they're on purely on on offense
right now. It's just every day they wake up and and that's what
opposition parties are supposed to do. >> Essentially,
nobody has time and nobody cares to watch the full context of
anything. And so there's there's a couple things that happen.
You can you can frame your opponents by only responding to certain
things they say, right? And Republicans are like masters of this.
They'll only respond to stuff that's like totally out to lunch
from Democrats to continue to build their narrative about Democrats
being like woke scolds and stuff, right? Like they will never
they'll never ever respond to like a Democrat going like I think
you know we should just make sure Americans earn a good wage.
No Republican will ever respond to that, right? So you get like
contentious stuff. It's usually contentious issues. Those are
the things that get clipped and responded to and
that's where all of the discourse is and that's what everybody
that's where everybody gets their characterization of both parties.
So I'm describing I'm literally just describing
like the culture war basically. Why wasn't it a 51 to to 49 for
every single uh or what I guess if if uh Vance had to do it.
I can't remember what the Senate makeup was at the time of the
confirmations. Like why did so many of them get through without
it having to come down to JD Vance's vote? Well, listen because
a lot of these senators are serving in states that Donald Trump
won by and they have a totally different Well, no, of course,
this is these are their constituents are majority Trump voters,
so they're going to probably make decisions that aren't going to
be the same as
well. What do you mean inexcusable? This is democracy, bro. Like,
what are you? >> No. The whole reason for representative
democracy is that we're saying, "Hey, we're going to vote you
into office because at the end of the day, you're the one that's
going to have all the aids and all the assistance and all the
information, and you're going to be the ones that are making
the best decisions. Otherwise, we have for a lot of issues, we
just dissolve them, and we just have national elections." Like,
where one vote, one person, one vote. And so, every [__]
issue, every law, every bill, like the majority of them go to
the [__] people to vote for because otherwise, Yeah.
I expect when it comes to these confirmation hearings, I don't
expect the [__] Democrats to to put [__]
Marco Rubio and Tulsa Gabbard into [__] office. >> Yeah.
Because I think you're looking at it from the perspective of
somebody that I mean where do you still do you live in
uh how do I put this? Unfortunately,
you probably as much as it sucks now because I absolutely hate
the foreign policy of this this government. As much as it sucks,
I don't think there's any way you win the Marco Rubio fight.
Okay, Marco Rubio is literally even though he is now like dictator
of multiple countries. Marco Rubio, even though that is the case,
he's actually the most reasonable person in that entire cabinet
somehow. I I know that's insane, but he's probably like one of
the more reasonable people in that candidate, sorry, cabinet.
It's very unfortunate. I don't know. I think that was the one
fight you probably couldn't win, as insane as it is to say now
in >> Um, Florida. I do. >> Okay. Okay. So, you live
in a red state? >> I do.
>> I have someone that's probably getting sick of hearing
from me. I >> I I think that you're you're looking at it
a terms of like a strict binary like the Democratic Party is
this perfect monolithic structure and and as a hive mind, you
know, we should >> Did I see I think I saw photoshops of
Marco Rubio is the Ayatollah now as well or something. [laughter]
I will admit I do think that meme is very funny. They just keep
they keep doing imperialism on different places and Marco Rubio
is gonna have to like run all of it. Figure it all out. Marco
Rubio, Sha of Iran, Ayatollah of Iran. Okay. Actually, dictator
of Cuba coming up. It >> all be unified on this, this,
and this.
Threat that we're facing. Yes, I do expect that monolithic view.
Yes. You're not going to
hold on, hold on, hold on, hold on, hold on. >> Shape-shifting
Rubio. Marco Rubio realizing he's probably gonna have to take
on the role of Secretary of War, too. [laughter]
He's He's got his TRT. He's He's hitting the weights. Okay. He's
got the tattoos. He's ready to go. He's ready to [__]
go. Oh my god.
Check Discord. Rubio. Oh. Oh, what the [__] dude?
What the hell? I didn't know this was a thing. Oh, this is a
very old thing. Hold on. Marco Rubio finding out he needs to
perform instead of Bad Bunny at the TPUSA halftime show. Marco
Rubio realizing he has to represent the Tongva tribe to reclaim
their land from Billy Isish.
>> you're not going to be able to effectively fight that
fistic threat if you don't win elections. And obviously, I think
that the blue senators that are serving in states that uh Trump
won and and uh blue representatives that are serving in districts
that Trump won, they have a totally different constituency, bro.
So, if they're taking those votes, it's probably because a decent
part of that constituency doesn't >> a Democrat party.
You would never accept this if some leftist was making some similar
analog. at the end of the day is is the basistic threat not the
ultimate threat to our democracy. >> If it is then why
install the people that the man who is the architect or whose
people he ends up hiring are the architects of project 2025.
Why should we ever tolerate a vote that helps further that agenda?
>> Are you act like the people that voted for the lake
and Riley act that enabled all this ice that's going on? Like
do you not have
their makeup their district is not really no I don't. Okay.
Now, the funny thing is,
I don't know, does Hutch not believe in like the ratchet effect?
Cuz like he understands
like it's basically describing just doing what MAGA does for
their for like their
congressional strategy, right? Like that's what Lykan's essentially
advocating for.
And uh as much as it grinds things to a halt and you need to
find a different solution, which is probably the real reason
for the paradigm shift, by the way, is that everything in the
current the way things are working, everything is ground to a
halt in Congress. There is no consensus whatsoever. You need
a paradigm shift of some kind because you need to start being
able to recapture majorities. You need to be able to start moving
the country again. Your country is like locked. It's paralyzed
at like a an incredibly important time in world history,
right?
Like that's that's the other thing is you know the concern
my concern is like basically private citizens gaining enough
power politically, technologically
even militarily that they become like threats in and of themselves
to western democracy. Right? That's my real concern. And if that's
a possibility, if it's going to be allowed, it's going to require
the paral the paralysis of Congress so that the American people,
the American government, the American apparatus can't move.
And a paradigm shift is one of the only things you could do to
like cure that in any way. >> That's where you and I differ.
>> And you're getting mad about someone else's constituency.
You don't live in those states. You don't live in those >> Decisions
ultimately affect the union, do they not? >> Yeah, of course
they do. But bro, I don't think that like slightly delaying Marco
Rubio's confirmation is going to do much to stop fascism. >> Yeah.
You know what it does? Like when the first State of the Union
from Donald Trump happens and Joe Green is the only dude willing
to say you and walk out and get kicked out every Al Green, whatever
his name is. The Democrats that all that >> That was the
guy I was looking for the other day. Al Green.
The guy who has to do he does like declarations every time.
I I can't. Hold on. Now I got to know cuz I always call him Joe
Green.
It's Al Green.
>> Al Green. You're right. Al Green.
>> Al Green like gets censured and Democrats vote for that.
Where's the constituent requirement for that?
>> Again, the any any politician that is serving in the
Congress is accountable to their voters. And so if they're taking
votes and they want to keep those jobs and not be like a one-term
senator or one-term representative, I assume it's because they
they are serving a district or a state.
How can you be blue no matter who for voters but not blue no
matter who for Congress? Like I I kind of
uh I kind of h I kind of understand
like a little bit like I don't think you should vote against
your constituents will like massively
like if you were in a pro-life district an overwhelmingly pro-life
district I do think you could maybe say I'm going to abstain
from voting on this right
but then if you're in a massively pro-life district you're not
a Democrat. So like I I'm just trying to think of like examples
I man I don't know
>> that you know want kind of more bipartisanship stuff.
Okay. >> Like do you understand that that's a huge chunk
of the country like a huge chunk of the country. In fact a vast
majority of the country bro
no let me finish my point. Hold that cuz I'm going to need you
to repeat it in a second. So I'm saying pause right there. Hold
on. I need you to repeat what you just said. I can't keep talking.
I need a drink. Give me one second. Okay. >> So I want
you to repeat it. I'm not trying to dodge it. We're gonna get
right back. >> I'm I'm gonna fill my thing of water, >> Okay.
I'll be right back. >> The point in safeguarding [laughter]
this country against >> a fullon fistic slide >> is
the fact that we have these really strong Democratic party candidates
that are winning in like red districts and states. Like there's
a not insignificant number of people in this country who voted
for Trump at the top of the ticket, but also voted for people
like Ruben Ggo in Arizona and Mark Kelly in Arizona and uh there's
like 12, you know, like um Democrats that you probably whose
voting records you probably load. um that that that beat the
Republican in that contest with in a in a race where Trump was
on the top of the ticket and
like
it's really unfortunate cuz there's like a meta level of strategy
happening where the Republicans are like brutally destroying
the Democrats, right?
Like the Republicans are totally obstinate will constantly run
towards the right
and they drag the entire like Overton window rightwards, right?
They refuse to ever work. And then Democrats are like, "Okay,
we have to be better about being bipartisan." So they've sprinted
right, you basically slightly move right and the whole Overton
window is shifting,
Like I don't know what it can't possibly shock you that you lose
people on the left and and have them like basically be apathetic
and not want to vote, right? And I think the other thing Republicans
did this h how do I even explain it? Republicans like fabricated.
They somehow it was like magic. It's unironic magic,
right? Like they basically just make things up. They just go
and make things up and they they're they're just winning. It's
like uh it's I don't know.
Like the focus on trans issues is just a great example where
like logically Democrats were not running on trans issues in
2024 at all in any way. Right. And the focus on it basically
somehow gets people on the Republican side. The average Republican
voter is voting. Sorry. The average the average voter starts
voting Republican in a way they wouldn't have before. It's like
I don't understand how bipartisanship helps there. I actually
don't know. I I really I actually don't know. Like how does trying
to be more bipartisan or more, you know, kind to middle of the
road voters? How does that help when they're sprinting, right?
I don't know if it helps. I actually don't know if I trust that
strategy.
It seems to me I'll always go back to this. It seems to me like
what's really happening is there's some subconscious thing kicking
in for people where they could just see how like kind of fake
the like the Dems don't really have a
there's like it sounds so insubstantial but it's like there's
a soul to the Republican party where they they have like some
underlying beliefs that they will always sort of echo back to
and with the Democrats it's just not there. If it's there it's
like we want to be inoffensive. We want to hurt as few people
as possible, which is like cool, but ultimately like do no harm
is not a is not like a it's sorry, I shouldn't say it's cool
because it's not cool. It's like a good or neutral ethos, but
the Republican agenda is like harm a few to do to help many or
something. I don't even know.
It just Yeah, I can't get I can't get away from the comparison
to Disney. Like Disney script writing is what the Democratic
Party feels like every time. totally crowdsourced, totally focus
grouped, no soul. >> And so I think
like listen, if you think that these senators and representatives
are are betraying the republic and enabling fascism and you know
um not doing enough to save off the threat of fascism, we have
a democratic remedy for this. You can run primaries against them.
You can, you know, you can take your shot and try to replace
them. But a lot of these senators are really popular. It's moderate
more quoteunquote moderate senators and representatives that
are um preventing the Republican major majorities from being
much bigger. And um >> and I'm happy that those people
exist and I'm happy that they have dees next to their name. But
I expect their voting record to uh be in concert with the ideals
of the Democratic party. And at this point in time, the Democratic
Party is the only one that is can stand on on 10 toes and say,
"Hey, uh we support democracy. We support the Constitution. We
support the longevity of, you know, the American experiment."
The Republicans cannot. But why would I not be within my right
to judge those who
like the other thing you probably have to grapple with is
the electoral strategy that is working for Republicans that has
worked for Republicans since 2016,
right?
This electoral strategy they've employed is essentially the one
like leftists are
like basically take a like a a more populist approach. basically
take your your beliefs but with a a super populist spin on them
and run with those super hard and just convince people like on
those issues. We're going to care about you. We're going to help
you. Right? Like they're basically arguing for like a left-wing
version of MAGA. We're going to we're just going to be about
our ideals. We're going to preach our ideals and we're going
to force it to work. Right? We're going to make it work in the
world. Yeah. I don't I don't know. It's like it sounds bad when
you say it like that, right? No. It's not like blue manga, though.
It's not like Democrat manga. like actually give me like populist
leftwing economics, populist leftwing policy that that does overlap
quite a bit with like some sort of socialist type thing, right?
It it really does. And I mean even even some of the stuff Trump
ran on originally would overlap with that. I'm just trying to
think it's like I don't know the evidence.
I'm like too tired. I'm going to let the caffeine action whether
or not I should
and that's not your representative. >> You have this huge
amount of heat for people who do not want to vote for certain
Democrats.
>> I don't know how these two positions can exist at the
same time. You're like, "Hey, you know what? They support
offend me the way those Democrats don't offend me in the same
way that they offend you." I >> Well, and you you almost
make you make your own reality here, Marty Epste. It's not even
like you appeal to nobody, but the Republicans make their own
reality by appealing to a certain group and trying to make that
group and those ideas cool, they pull more people into that group,
right? If the if the Democrats could find the thing, this all
goes back to the same Richard Spencer comment that haunts my
dreams. Okay, it haunts me.
It's a Richard Spencer comment. He was talking to Destiny in
like 2024 on No Jumper and he said liberalism at least liberalism
like in the west like how we think of it right now in America.
It is the ring around Hitler. Everything is okay except Hitler
or anything Hitler stood for. And so liberalism is the ring around
Hitler. Now
unfortunately there are a couple ways you can like organize yourselves
into groups such that you have like a coherent nation. You can
do it on religion. You can do it on nationality. You can do it
on ethnicity. Well, America is a multi-thnic country. Can't really
do anything about that, right? It is a multi-thnic country.
America is a like a secular country by definition. You can't
really rally around around um religion. And so, unfortunately,
the the the final element you have is rallying around nationalism.
And liberalism sort of pushes against that by definition.
And I don't know how I don't know. And that's what the Republicans
are doing, right? Rallying around nationalism. And they keep
making it a part of their brand and making it cool.
And it's like it's this whole thing where I I think it was a
Taftage tweet I saw in this today where it's like basically like
white people have traumatized themselves after World War II by
taking Hitler and making everything Hitler ever wanted like sacrilege.
And it's like there there are pieces around it that shouldn't
be. Like nobody's arguing that like genocides are cool, right?
Nobody's arguing that. But there's this thing with like the nationalism,
the way you argue about being proud of your country, proud of
your culture, proud of your traditions. Like a lot of that is
seen as rightwing. And I don't know how else you organize your
country right now. How do you organize and like get people who
aren't bought in? How do they even join a group you're a part
of?
Like somebody who just loves like they're Americans. They don't
share any other overlap with you, right? And you are the party
that doesn't love America, right? I don't what? Where's Where's
your organizing principle?
Marks was right. Oh, you guys are so
This is why you guys can't ever win.
You don't understand how human beings work. You You basically
ah I had
Sorry, I can't with the with the atomization stuff. It doesn't
work. >> I recognize that. >> By the way, that all
by the way, even with Markx the USSR, Are you telling me the
USSR didn't have nationalism?
You telling me the USSR didn't have nationalism right now? It's
like you use different words for the same concept. Me in a state
like California, especially in the Los Angeles County, I am I
live in a constituency that is wildly different from like the
median town in Arizona or you know, Texas or uh you know, North
Carolina. And so if I see a senator that takes a vote at >> Oh,
I'm agreeing with Marks. Okay, I see. Okay, sure. Uh that's not
genius stuff. It's just it's like appealing to nationalism is
one way you can identify and and collect with your with your
people. And when you don't have that like ability to collect
around some some sort of like tag or label,
that's really difficult. And I think that's what liberalism is
is basically arguing that a lot of those labels, if they're ever
sufficiently big enough, they're like bad. They're scary. There's
like something happening there that it works against it. And
I think that's one of that's one of the big things the Democrats
need to fix for I don't [clears throat] like it bothers me sometimes,
but I don't, you know, I'm not I'm not this guy that's over here
saying we need to primary them after every vote that I don't
like. >> They need to be primary after every vote, but
there are certain votes that Yeah. I think that you know what,
this is like, hey, you've done your time and if the if it comes
down to it and it's in my district and at the end of the day,
they don't get primary. I'm still going to vote for the because
at the end of the day, it's better to have them in office than
a Republican, right? I don't disuck agree with that whatsoever.
But I am going to say until that [__] day comes,
you're a piece of [__] You shouldn't have [__]
voted to confirm these people. But again, >> bro, this
is like such a guys like they are the minority party in the Senate.
They can't stop these confirmations from >> They can't
stop that. That's the thing is like all I I feel I feel that
I feel helpless as a Democrat and I feel for my party because
the Democratic party does not have the power to just go ahead
and they don't have a majority that they can go ahead and use
against the president. They can't, right? I understand that.
But that doesn't mean that I don't want to see shows of force.
So, I would have like like everyone sitting down like [__]
Elizabeth Waring for standing up for Trump. Like I [__]
that [__] right? Does it mean I want her to be primar?
No. Am I [__] annoyed? Yes. Did she stand up for
something that was genuinely good for the people? Yes. So, when
she looked at that [__] person who was clearly giving
her the stink eye for standing up and she shrugs and says, "Sorry,
it's good." And keeps clapping.
Everybody's like, "The Nordic countries don't have this problem.
The Nordic countries don't have this problem." Again, uniting
principles, gay, ethnicity, religion,
nationality. It turns out there's one thing the Nordics can all
agree on and that's that they're >> Do I get it? Yes. Do
I think it was bad? >> You You automatically get You automatically
get the So I'm saying ethnicity. I might mean race. I don't really
understand the distinction between the two. I'm saying visible
look of each other. They look alike a lot. >> Solidarity
also. Yes. Do I think that those in a time when we are unprecedented
wait when we do not have the power to make explicit actions and
use our majorities to you know usurp the will of the dictator
to be yeah I I I understand that we can't do that that's why
those little shows of of resistance are important. So yes, seeing
51 to 50 down the ballot on these confirmations would have been
a really great thing to see and it would have been motivating
to the people, but it doesn't do that when they just go ahead
and they're like, well, or hey, I know Mark Marco, we used to
play golf. He's going to be fine. He's not going to be, you know,
he's he's one of the more establishment Republicans that have
existed for all these years. He's not going to, you know, do
all the crazy. No, man. This mother >> Marco Marco's like
was like one of the least offensive people. Yeah, I feel like
I feel like everybody came into the Trump administration and
everybody who brought got brought into that cabinet was basically
like, "Okay, we're actually doing like we're doing like maximal
corruption here." So, what's the one thing your donors want most
of all? Oh, Marco, you're getting a lot of money from sugar plantation
owners, right? From big sugar down in Florida there. Oh, and
they're all they're all Cuban. They're all Cub Cuban immigrants.
They want the Okay, we'll overthrow the Cuban regime. Okay, we're
putting that in the pot. You're in, Marco. You're in. Now you're
gonna look the other way when I'm corrupt and we're gonna get
we're gonna overthrow Cuba. We'll do it, Marco. Okay. It's like
that's what they did with everybody who came in, right? They're
just like, "What's the What's the one thing that would make your
donors come?" Oh, you the the overthrow of the Cuban regime.
Let's go. Yeah, we can throw that in the pot. We can throw that
in the pot. >> Going to try to invade Cuba one day. >> So,
yeah, I'm going to be upset when he when that does happen. We
do take military action against Cuba. I'm going to be really
[__] upset at every single Democrat that voted to
confirm
Oh, they're not going to have to take military. Unfortunately
for Cuba, it's within the US's sphere of influence and the US
is perfectly capable of economically like devastating that country
in every possible way. Okay? It's a like the US does not have
to do military action on Cuba. The US could literally starve
Cuba in like out of existence, right? They could if they wanted
to. They won't. They'll buckle. It's like, dude, they they'll
never have to put like boots on the ground in Cuba. It's just
never going to be a requirement. I mean, I just I frankly think
this is such a waste of >> and realistically, I think that's
just the strategy in it's the strategy everywhere, right? We're
going to destroy your quality of life. We're going to your country
into the dirt until you give in.
We're going to destroy that's the strategy in Iran. That was
the strategy in Venezuela. That's the strategy in Cuba. Your
way of life will be destroyed until you aced to whatever we want.
We control you. You didn't know we control you, but we do control
you. Okay. You thought this was like a You thought this was like
a global capital market where anybody could could transact. Nope.
That's been at the That's been at the benevolence of the United
States the entire time this global market has existed. It is
only through the goodwill of the United States that you have
access to these markets at all. And guess what? Those markets
can go away at any time. This is kind of the thing, Mark. Now,
Mark Carney wasn't talking about this directly, but it applies
in the same way, right? you have access to these markets. And
I I suggest I feel bad because I said this is probably the thing.
This is some Zhan talk. Like this is where I learned about this
paradigm and it it's obviously true cuz Trump is literally using
that to the planet. Okay. But it's like the US controls all waterways.
There's nobody else who can do it. If you want goods, you have
to be allowed to have those goods by the US essentially. And
there are like cutouts to this possibly, but it more or less
works because of how integrated the global like supply chains
are. It more or less works for everybody that if you want anything,
you have already bought into a system where the US is the the
kingpin. Okay, China has enough productive capacity that China
is a big player there too. But it's it's not because China can,
you know, stop you from getting stuff. It's because China can
stop providing stuff to you or they could just with, you know,
inputs however they like. But it
Yeah, it's um that's why he wants Greenland in the Arctic Sea,
too. Yeah, that'll be a part of it. Yep. 100%. Oh, sorry. It's
it's like most of it. It's about controlling trade up there.
It's just Yeah, basically being able to shut down those waterways,
being the only country that controls waterways, right? And so,
yeah, the the US So, Mark Carney talked about how oh, well, with
tariffs, we're realizing that the US like US and China, they
can leverage these countries and so we can't just be dependent
on the US cuz the US actually can just over at any given time,
right? He's he's even leaving out the fact that like all the
US really has to do is basically say, "Hey, hey, Russia,
we're not going to do anything. Hey, um like you know when we're
really going to be is when this is one of the things Zion predicts
will happen. Okay. Eventually, as the US pulls back from protecting
waterways, um especially for countries they don't like, there
will be as a natural consequence of that a return to piracy.
Like actual piracy, like imagine private merkantile people. I
say merkantile because I'm thinking of the merkantile age, but
private like privateeers, literal privateeers
like Peter Teal or Elon Musk buying submarines, commissioning
submarines so that they can like sink shipping container like
container ships that are going to other countries. Like imagine
like that happening cuz the only thing that prevents that from
happening is the fact that the US has the dominant navy and they
don't want that happening.
But if the US is no longer buying things from like the Chinese
sphere of influence, let's say they move they they move a lot
of their shipping to Central America, South America, they're
no longer buying things from the the Chinese sphere of influence.
What incentive is there for the US with their navy to protect
that sphere of influence from attack? There's none, right? It's
not even where I spend most of my time and energy, but it's something
that like as we've come to it, it's like, yeah, I'm upset the
same way that I But what doesn't make sense to me is how you
can hold this position, but then someone says, "Yeah, I'm sorry.
I can't vote for Camala. Um because she has shown no sign that
she's going to lead the Democratic party in a direction that
is not going to continue funding, you know, what's happening
in Gaza. And you want to bring up the USA and the 14 million
deaths and guess what? I've actually worked with USA. I totally
agree. I've had coffee from the beans from some dude who rose
his own goddamn coffee beans and he was over there in Afghanistan
with me. Like I love those [__] people. I love the
exercise of soft power. >> Oh, I see. Oh, no. LIKE IT.
DON'T DO IT. LIKE IT. IT'S A COUNTERPOINT STORY. NO. LIKE IT.
what US
could see the bloodshed happening in
or unwilling
to have a hold on let's be really clear because this is something
that another issue that I've had is like that you can't even
empathetically understand even if you're like yeah but cuz you
and me at least I'm a yeah but guy I'm a yeah but Democrats are
going to be better the idea that Donald Trump would have been
in any way shape or form better on Gaza than Camala is absolutely
insane and every dumb including Hassan and everyone else who
used their platforms and didn't just righteously rage and say,
"You've got to vote them. I don't give a [__] You've
got to vote them. It's going to be better for Gaz. It's going
to be better for this country." They're wrong. So, can we before
I move on to finish my point, you you grasp that I am a vote
blue no matter who kind of guy?
>> I I don't I don't I don't have any reason to to doubt
your
then I at the very least can look at someone who says, "Yeah,
I have a problem with all these people dying and my congressman
voted to support and send more aid to them. I can't vote for
them." Like you I see no empathy for that position. I just see
treating them as if they are Republicans themselves and I that
doesn't
>> I have empathy unless I missed the the claims
that sorry
>> I have empathy for like the the feelings like the emotions
that people feel. I have empathy for your feeling of powerlessness
and um like anger. Um, of course I empathize with I listen, I
deeply empathize with like if you're a young person in this country
and Gaza is your number one issue and uh you had red lines along
that kind of thing. I I intensely empathize with that because
I went through the same thing when I was their age. Literally,
I did this. I was the same thing like when the war in Iraq kicked
off. >> Hold on. What is Oh, he's gonna say something crazy
here, isn't he? I feel like he's gonna say something crazy >> 19
years old or 20 years old. I can't remember exactly how many
how old I was. >> Damn. I am. Um >> I thought we
were the same [laughter] >> No. And I thought about that
conflict every day obsessively every and this was before social
media. So, you know, I was in college at the time and you know,
maybe I talked to some people at my school about it, but I wasn't
like I didn't have this online kind of I mean,
how you know the US like the US basically admits like we were
we were in Iraq, right? I'm pretty sure the US admits like we
adopted an initial strategy that was insanely punitive and only
worked against us and only once we started trying to win hearts
and minds did we have any success in Iraq. We still lost. We
still lost in the end but like
overall okay overall
[laughter]
h it was only it was it worked against us. It hurt us so badly,
right? That like it it just doesn't. So when when Hutch is like
I was against it, it's like I'm pretty sure everybody knows you
should have been against the way the US approached that war and
specifically after they toppled Saddam as well, right? Iraq and
Afghanistan, I think they were they were very punitive to begin
with, right? And then they eventually realized that, oh, urban
insurgencies, well, this is more in Iraq. Urban insurgencies,
you can't fight them without the citizenry on your side. If the
citizenry thinks you're just like the evil invaders, you're
always infinitely. Okay. Once you've gotten to the point where
the citizenry is willing to participate and risk themselves to
engage in attacks against you, like they're willing to risk themselves
to h to hide soldiers. They're willing to risk themselves to
like lure you into traps. You're it's super over, man. You cannot
win against that without just wiping them out. Like it's then
then you're just seeing like, okay, yeah, we just have to wipe
you out now, right? So, if you're not willing to go all the way
to like total holocaust on whatever urban insurgency you're working
against, then hearts and minds is the only strategy. A boiling
cauldron of rage. Um, but I I was furious every day thinking
about what we were doing. And um, you know, when 2004 came along,
I thought for sure Bush was going to lose because by that point
it had been clear that there wasn't any WMD in Iraq and the thing
was starting to become a bit of a quagmire. a lot of American
soldiers were dying and uh he won he won re-election and I became
completely disillusioned with politics and so I do I do understand
very like I I it's not the same right but I I do understand that
feeling what I don't understand is why you think it's inappropriate
for me to spend time
or the amount of time that I spend criticizing the people that
I think are
obfiscating the truth um often times just like lying uh and and
feeding into this apathy Yeah, I can answer >> With these
constant constant um obfiscations and falsehoods and um >> I
can answer that. >> And and appeals to to tribalism over
pragmatism. Um >> I can the word you just used tribalism
over pragmatism. I do not see you in any way, shape, or form
trying to build a bridge. And if if you want to tell me that
you've just given up hope, then I'd say
with just their audiences, like these people like if you if you
want to like the idea that you know, >> you can't try to
reach these people. That is what I have a huge issue with. >> No,
that's not true though. I did
>> it is past tense. There's still a two elections coming
up that are the most important for years. I did for years >> and
I and I didn't like that's the thing is I came from the like
anti-lefty [__] like 2019 to 2000 whenever the [__]
I stopped doing streaming like my [__] feed was all
full of this [__] like it it was rage against everyone
from Assign to Mike from PA to the surfs and all this stuff like
and and now I've just realized like for these people are way
more close to our views than Republicans and at the end of the
day like I don't
the these the people is in the the broader lefty [__]
space but yeah you know what yeah I'll [__] say I
think Hassan is closer to us than [__] Republicans.
Absolutely.
But I don't want to get I don't we can have that debate another
time. Like my point is I believe that and but more importantly
his audience is more likely to be amunable to voting Democrat
than the Republicans are. >> Well, I mean listen I think
listen I think that might be true. Um but but >> but I
want to see coalition building. I want to see relationship building.
I want to see outreach. If you want to have debate >> if
you're if this is really about effective coalition building,
why aren't you just as angry as I am when these people constantly
>> I am but I don't obsess over it. I tweet about it and
I get out [laughter] of my system and that's it. There's more
to focus on. >> Like it. Like it. We are talking about
>> Dude, I'll be honest. I think that might be true. Um
but I want to see coalition building. I want to see relationship
building. I want to see outreach. If you want to have if this
is really about effective coalition building, why aren't you
just as angry as I am when these people constantly I am, but
I don't obsess over it. I tweet about it and I get it out of
my system and that's it.
>> Marty Epste, thank you for the five gifted. Let's go.
Thank you. Thank you. Thank you. >> You're talking about
focus on >> liken liken. We are talking about people with
a collective audience pool of probably like millions and millions
and millions of people that probably skew a little bit younger
in the United States and these are people that constantly every
day like lie to their audience about uh like Democratic party
candidates. Like, doesn't it bother you when um like Kyle Kolinsky
and Hassan [__] and the I've had it lady and I' like
five other gigantic leftist influencers make the claim that um
Gavin Newsome vetoed singlepayer in California. Don't you think?
>> Yeah. I get I get upset because what I'm not seeing
is I'm not seeing thoughtful commentary and correcting the record.
What I am seeing is lefty derangement about I see these >> I
call this stuff out so so specifically, bro. I call this stuff
out so specifically every day. I have never
>> did Jennifer Welch talk Welsh Welch whatever talk about
that. Like the thing is is to me it seems like the primary problem
that most people have with this Jennifer Welch lady >> is
that she goes after
>> or sorry she's nice to Hassan. That seems to be the
primary issue, right? >> That I've never seen that from
you or any of these other people that [__] go consistently
after this group. I have never seen that kind of thoughtful.
Why why are you why do you have so so much smoke for me when
I'm pointing out their lies and >> I I'll answer that that's
on a more personal level. It's because again like I saw you as
this like pragmatic in here for the right reasons kind of commentator
and now the commentary I see is like overindexing for these people
in a way that is not helpful at all. And it it goes back to I'll
use that debate again. The heat you had for the [__]
the the you know agitative protesters in LA was greater than
the heat you had for the US government. to the point that yes,
I think that anything more than just, hey, we really need to
stop this one tweet, done with it, the end. But like the the
debate panels and the tweets and all that, it's like [__]
it, man. At the end of the day, the thing that really matters
in this moment is the fact that Donald Trump sent troops into
US city to [__] 12 protests. That is what the biggest
issue is. And there should be no question whether or not that
should be the >> here. I get frustrated because you have
these enormous protests that are organized by liberal groups
that are not like radicals and they'll explicitly
um advertise these protests as nonviolent.
And I see it happen over and over. I watched it happen with my
own eyes at No Kings where the vast majority of people at No
Kings were um joyous handing out like um like hand lotion and
suntan lotion and water bottles. People are playing music. It's
like one of those kind of vibes and like clockwork every time
you have this other element that show up and try to co-op that
um explicitly non dude. Dude, okay,
bro.
This is the g Oh, this is the worst. I hated this when they did
this with Hassan as well. um like this idea that actually actually
when you think about it guys, we're like liberals are the ones
running all these protests and then socialists show up and like
like man I'm sorry you you can get mad at lefties for a lot of
stuff. You can't get mad at them for not being the ones who like
organize and show up to protest. Okay. I I feel like lefties
are the ones who quite literally take on the burden of being
unemployed so that they can show up to protest. Okay. Okay. They're
like the ones who show up every time. What are we doing? This
is like the one thing they're actually reliable for. Okay. What
do you mean showing up? If anything, if liberals are showing
up, it's a co-opt. Okay. The
lefties have a principal commitment to being unemployed so they
can show up at any protest at any time. Okay? Let's be real.
Let's be real. >> Violent protest and turn it into a physical
confrontation with cops. Like, I saw it with my own eyes. I was
standing literally feet away from a group of people who were
very clearly like a different kind of like element from the from
the from the main no kings like protesters. These kids were young.
They were angry. They showed up to where uh like federal um military
presence was. I watched them start throwing [__]
at the cuffs. Like I watched them literally initiate violence.
>> Yeah. But I have but I I don't like doing that. I don't
like seeing that. I don't engage in that. That's fine. But I
still don't have the heat from them that I do for the government.
At the end of the day, I do not have the heat
>> bro. I showed up to a no king's protest to demonstrate
and uh experience solidarity with other people in my area that
were um disgusted by this administration. That that was the whole
point. What I'm saying is like those people showing up and agitating
all that stuff. At the end of the day, I'm not going to go [__]
if I was a goddamn journalist, I wouldn't go home and write about
them. I would still write about the fact that the United States
government sent troops in to quell a protest. I would just say
that like you totally disavow that and you're fine with like
force being used to maintain the safety of officers if they're
being attacked, but that like I would try to find the facts and
figure out who's encroaching on who. How is that like getting
laid out? I definitely saw stuff at the No Kings protest where
actually protesters had to be cleared out with force because
they're like there's some cops trapped like under a bridge. I
don't know how they got there, but they started getting rocks
thrown down in them and I'm like, "Oh, that actually needs to
stop." Like big rocks, too. Not little rocks. We watched some
dude get domed on stream. Okay,
now that's one of those cases where I'm like, actually, that's
unacceptable.
That needs to not happen. And they do need to push these people
out cuz it's going crazy. All right.
Yeah, it's uh there's like there's cases where like I would be
against the protesters. There's cases where I'd be against the
cops.
>> I talked about Hold on. Hutch's brilliance about this.
Wait, wait, wait, wait. What is this? We got a clip. >> It
is.
I just think is it I mean listen >> is it not kind of comical
that uh he's been given this commentary about like oh yeah that's
standard issue uh weaponry
>> that's usually a surefire sign that things are about
to pop off and he's been doing that for like an hour and so far
it seems like the police are showing
>> no way [laughter] they start firing pepper balls in
like two seconds don't >> be like fish
>> like they're not advancing. They issued a dispersal
order and they hasn't they haven't advanced.
>> Oh yeah. No, they use that technology in uh Colombia.
Oh, okay. Sorry. Oh, [__] me. Right.
It's just Listen, could have happened to anybody, but very funny
that it happened to Hutch. Okay. Very funny. Very, very, very
funny. I'm sorry. So, so funny. Okay, dude.
I just want to just cuz I know it'll upset people. I just want
to shout out how cool Hassan looks in his press vest and Keia
and he's got like the outfit. He's got like the the whole garb.
Okay. And I just want to point out how cool that looks. Okay.
He looks so cool in this garb that he's got on. All right. He's
got the watches and [__] He's so cool. He's just
so cool. [laughter]
>> Oh, sorry. I can't I can't help myself. You did, but
you spend so much time talking about the lefties.
>> What? What? You seem to think that like sh So, should
I never talk about them or I shouldn't talk about them as much
as I >> As much as you do. Like, you want to call something
out that is false? Fine. You if you show me that, not that you
owe me anything. Okay, so let's take it out. I don't have that
big of an ego, but like as far as what's upsetting me, I want
to see like a greater heat for the bigger issue than the lefties.
But what I see, >> you already have so many creators that
do that. >> Yeah, but those they're right. And we don't
we need more of that. We don't need any more focus. We need more
of that. So, hold on. That's the thing. That's where it gets
back to like at the end of the day is if this is just because
it it helps. And look, like I get it. This is a flippant thing
that I can't say, I'd have to mute the stream right now. Hold
on. Actually, I'm going to mute. One second.
Uh because like it's going to mute. I'm going to tell you exactly
what he's going to say. How do you disconnect the fact that you
make way more money by ragging on Hassan than you do for your
political takes? That like your political takes don't really
have a market, but they're ragging on Hassan has a market, and
you make a lot of money from that. How do you disconnect that
and make a like a dispassionate analysis this situation and figure
out what's actually good for people versus just good for you
right now? Maybe like will say less than that, but it's basically
the the question will be how do you know that you're helping
people versus just making money off of them? And like
it seems clear to me that you focus on this because it is something
that makes you money, generates you view viewership. Okay. >> Okay,
guys. Are you streaming right now?
>> Okay. I'm muting. So, this is sincere. >> It's
definitely It's definitely going to be exactly what I said. I'm
sorry. It's definitely going to be exactly what I said. I don't
even need to. >> But I I agree. Which is why which is why
I think people should more people should be talking about this.
I think I think I don't think there's enough people talking about
this. I think that their impact on the discourse is corrosive
and toxic and um I think it depresses turnout. I think it depresses
voter >> I agree with there's no disagreement that with
me either. Like I think at the end of the day, >> yeah,
given the end of the conversation, I'm 100% confident that I
just got that totally correct. people do not like the the leftists
and all that stuff. Like there's too much heat for the Dems.
But another thing that I have an issue with is that a lot of
that becomes thought terminating. Like do you know how many times
like I I I'm pretty decently versed in like our Middle Eastern
uh uh policy and like our intelligence community's like history.
And so anytime that I have any criticism that is substantively
based on like actual history and rooted in fact like you know
many times I hear America bad, America bad. That's all I can
cares about is America bad. Like when I'm [laughter] any one
of these leftists would consider me a CIA shill. It's [__]
infuriating and it's thought terminating and I hate seeing that
[__] come from this the party that's supposed to
be the more intellectually honest and uh educated.
>> If you agree that that's a problem, then why would you
disagree that somebody needs to point this out and talk about
>> because it needs to be done pragmatically and that's
what I don't see. I see points. >> What does that mean?
>> Uh that's implied by him using all of my rhetoric to
dismantle Hutch right now. Okay.
People think that straight raid's controlling Lykan. I'm actually
controlling like direct. I'm not. I'm not. I'm not. Please don't
take that seriously. pragmatically means again in a way that's
going to like kind of try to woke up that is >> I woke
up and I saw I got linked like Dan trying to snark on this conversation
and I was like oh I can just go live and coast off of this cuz
I don't I have no plan for the day. Okay that's I'm I'm I'm not
I'm not cabaling. I'm not making plans. I'm not doing anything.
I'm just >> going to try to reach these people and change
their minds and not just use them as content bod
you >> there is no changing their minds my friend. I I
I don't focus on directly with [laughter] these people at all.
>> You just said it was you just said it was a problem
that depresses voter >> It is a problem that depresses
voter turnout. But if you can't change their minds, focus on
the people that need to be motivated to go out and vote and already
care. But if their audience can't be
I think I am
makes people want to go vote. I think >> I I think the
question is does Hutch's engagement
undepress the turnout or not? What is Hutch what is the effect
of Hutch's engagement? Right.
I would say, and I've seen this over time, unironically, nobody
nobody believes it. Nobody thinks it. Sorry. Nobody
uh how do I explain this? The best solution is to ignore. If
you don't like somebody, if you don't want them to have success,
the best solution is very often, almost always to ignore them.
Okay? Now, that can have down that can have like uh downsides
for you personally, but it's usually to ignore them. It's to
not give any oxygen to it because as soon as you turn something
into a fight, people can take sides and they love participating
in fights. They love taking sides and like trying to lynch people.
Okay, make this clip worthy. Damn it. No, I'm trying not to be
clipped right now. Okay,
ignoring is better a lot of the time.
That's all. If you want clips, I could I could try to think of
something after. I'll wait until Hush says something particularly
stupid. Okay, and I'll pop off for you. All right, substance
policies of the Republican party. That's >> I can't even
tell you. That's why Hassan started watching Hutch clips. Well,
Hassan started watching Hutch clips because here's the thing,
none of these people, it can have downsides for you. When somebody's
like snarking on you or lying about you, that can have downsides
for you. But in terms of like, is that actually going to fix
or help a significant systemic issue. No, you just want to win
that war against them, right? You're not helping against a systemic
issue. When I talk about Destiny, I'm not helping about some
systemic issue. I'm not helping with some systemic issue. Likewise,
when he talks about me or my community, not helping with something,
it's like just a personal thing, okay? Some personal either personal
ethics or whatever. It's not I I would never try to say I'm like
standing up for victims or something. That's not what I'm doing,
okay? That's not what this is. If you think that's what it is,
you're mis you're misinformed, you're misunderstood, right? It's
not it's not that.
Okay? Likewise for Destiny standing up for like people who get
snarked on or standing up for Hutch when he gets bullied. This
nothing. It's all petty personal [__] Okay? I'm just
honest about it. I can't first of all I do talk about Donald
Trump all the time and second of all I can't even tell you how
many people that are >> oh anyway but the the question
was the the comment was that's why Hassan started watching Hutch
clips cuz Hassan's tired of being snarked on that he doesn't
like it right he doesn't like it so he's not trying to help democracy
or something by mocking Hutch he's saying you're lying about
me so [__] you
>> regulars in my audience >> I hope Destiny's orbiters
realize Hutch is a husten snarker and has no interest in politics
maybe they'll will kick him out of the coalition. LOL.
>> I don't think this is something you have to purity test
on. You just convince Hutch over time that like this isn't effective,
right? That going in on on Trump and all this other stuff is
more
right? That's that's all. They don't have to kick him out of
the coalition. I don't need anybody I don't need anybody to be
kicked out of any coalition. You don't have to purity test somebody
out. It's just over time Hutch is going to be convinced that
that wasn't the way to go. I believe I believe that. Okay.
Um, Jto is a tireless advocate for women and other POC. Yeah,
I was just advocating for malaria vaccines to Africa like two
seconds ago on Twitter. You guys not see the post? Hold on, let
me pull the post up.
Um, if you support US strikes against Iran for the benefit of
Israel, then shut the up about US aid being used to send malaria
vaccines to Africa.
Only the lowest rung of will argue empathy for Israel and nobody
else.
See, I'm advocating for women to get a vaccines in Africa. Hey,
if you're like supporting these strikes, but you also hate US
ID, you are a you are the lowest rung of you are propagandized.
You're okay. Thank you. Thank you for listening to my message.
That send me emails to tell me like, hey, I I want to thank you
for, you know, pulling me out of that. Like, I get I get I get
constant emails about this. I get constant people typing in my
chat about this thing. And so, I just I >> Uh-huh. I definitely
I definitely believe that. I definitely constant emails. Constant
emails. No way. I I really am >> can't process the idea
that you agree that the way that they cover politics depresses
turnout, but you disagree with the way that I covered it. And
like if it's about proportionality or like, well, you need to
do like 70% Trump and and 30% this. I just reject that out. >> You
can't say in chat. Shockingly, that's like the one thing that's
There are going to be some creators that are more in their element
and more effective focusing on a particular thing. Like Josiah
focuses basically 100% of his efforts on Republicans and these
kinds of things. And I think that's like super useful and I think
that that helps to inform people about what's going on and maybe
motivate them to vote. Same thing with like Brian Tyler Cohen
or David Pacman or you know a lot of other like more kind of
center-left uh liberal um channels. Um that's their niche. That's
where they've found the most success. That's the thing that they
want to talk about the most. >> Help convince me. What
do you think your focus on them is doing for our cause?
>> Well, the hope is to offer a counternarrative, one that
is actually rooted in honesty and the truth and to pull people
out of that space. I think the space that Assan occupies and
it's not just him, it's like a whole ecosystem of creators. And
there's a there's another element too here where he he has like
a literal cultter personality going on over there. And so he
has like a series of like incentives and disincentives to defend
him, to repeat the stuff that he says. Um, but it the problem
is so much bigger than >> Do you think that you'll reach
those people though by just dunking on their
>> Like a cult of personality.
I don't know. Is that true? H, it's probably getting close to
true. Maybe Hutch is talking about Hassan for sure. Yes, he's
definitely talking about Hassan purely.
But then, but then I h
it's just so not introspective at all.
It makes me feel weird to hear Hutch say >> I'm telling
you I do. The number I do. >> I I believe you do. I totally
believe you do. But I assume that your email does not account
for even 1% of the size of Hassan's reach, right?
>> I mean, what what logic is this? >> Well, I'm
just saying I don't know if it's realistic that I'm going to
take like 10% of his audience or 50%. >> Right. But do
you if you this is the power you have as an audience by the way
as well that like basically 99% of the audience 99.9% of the
audience never interacts with the creator in any other way. Creators
don't get that many messages or that even big creators don't
get that many messages that many DMs that many emails. You can
basically always make a difference. You if you like some behavior
from a creator, send them an email or something. Watch how big
a difference it makes. Cuz even people with like 3 4 5,000 concurrence,
they get an email from somebody like basically laying out, oh,
thank you for doing this for me. You have no idea how strong
that is. That's if you want to just like But you you can only
do it in a positive sense. You have to feed their ego every time.
You can only do it in a positive way. Okay.
No, no, that's not Bon's like Iranian. He's Iranian diaspora.
Don't I I might cover the Bjon stuff later, but I'm just saying
if you you have to do it positively. You have to you have to
um like soothe or or inflame ego, okay? You can't do it you can't
do it through critique. That will not work. But you can go, "Oh,
this really made a big difference for me when you did this."
Makes a massive difference for like every creator. Okay? Because
Hutch probably that's like probably 0.01% of Hutch's engagement
is like people saying, "Oh, you know, you helped me with this
on, right?
You are reaching people now. Do you think you would reach more
people if you did it in a way that actually didn't make them
feel like you're just completely adversarial?
>> There's I am matching their energy to fine. Matching
the energy is an excuse often used to do stupid bad [__]
So what I'm saying is do you think that if you were better as
far as the way that you approach it, it was more pragmatic and
it was less hostile. Do you think that you would reach more people
if that is your ultimate goal and what you think the value is
and what you're doing? Do you think you would reach more people
if you changed your approach in a way that didn't make them look
at you immediately as an adversary to be ignored? >> I
think this is decidedly not the case. I think that especially
with the things that do best on social media and the internet,
it's way more uh conflict driven than, you know, killing them
with kindness. You know, I think like you're maybe looking for
like a um like a good example of of of a tactic that maybe you're
pushing for here is I don't know if you saw the debate that Adam
Mockler had with um >> Yeah, I saw a decent amount of it.
>> Maybe you're pushing for that kind of strategy. I listen
>> um the kindness thing can work.
it it no the kindest thing can totally work but oh how do I put
it for anybody's it's going to work for if they're in like some
kind of cult of personality they're not the kindest thing can
work with people who probably would have worked their way out
of those communities to begin with right
the kindness thing is never going to work to to deprogram people
who are in some kind of cult I've I've trust me I've tried I've
watched it fail repeatedly I've watched it fail enough in my
own personal experience of being like kind to people and explaining
things and they agree with me and they go back to the cult and
their their opinion just goes back to whatever their environment
was, right? It it doesn't work for the people who are entrenched.
It doesn't work. I can just tell you that factually. It doesn't
work. >> I like Monler a lot and I >> I wish it did
work. I believe in it a lot cuz that's how people would get me.
But it's not how it's not how you get mo it's not how you like
break down that system if you want to do that. Unfortunately
for Hutch, he's not funny enough or intelligent enough or anything.
He's got like none of the attributes that would be required to
break that down. And unfortunately, he's made some adversaries
that have all of those things. So, he's not going to You will
not win this war, Hutch. You will not win this war. Okay. So,
I I don't know what to tell you. Hutch is in a a rough position
cuz he just justified basically everybody who says bad things
about him. He justified all of that in the past like 30 seconds.
Okay? He he totally justified every time I pull up his stuff
on my stream and I laugh at him and I make fun of him. He's justified
all of that, right? That's all
for sure. So,
I just I feel like he and it's not going to be beneficial to
him long term, but >> I found myself to like very disappointed
with that debate at many times. I thought like he was strong
in some cases but he was just so eager to concede like he was
conceding things that he should not have been conceding and he
was doing it for the sake of like being cordial and not having
the conversation become too adversarial and then and then and
then it just becomes like counterproductive in his mind. >> So
please Lykan
Lykan please you can break him on this because he is himself
not sincere.
You could break him on this by just saying, "So, you're saying
Adam Mockler was griing?" He was griing in that conversation
with Hassan.
He was saying things that he didn't believe. He was not standing
up to the conversation so he could maintain a connection and
earn more money. He's griing.
And Hutch, as much as Hutch believes that in his heart, if assuming
everything else he's saying is true, Hutch would have to believe
that in his
But is Hutch strong enough to say it?
Absolutely not. Absolutely no way he says that. Okay. Right.
But in doing that, he was way too consiliatory. I >> I
can I think I can agree with No, I I can agree with that. There
were some things I wouldn't have conceded, but overall, I liked
his approach. And overall, I think his audience probably even
if there were I don't care what the [__] chat says.
I hate chat says it's just like Twitter says articles. It's meaningless
and at the end of the day, like there are people that were watching
that that may not have chatted, that may not have commented,
that may be lurkers that were way more amanable to what Mockler's
points were than uh than otherwise would have if Mach just come
and been like, you know, [__] you. you're [__]
kidding.
>> But that that's what I'm saying. Like, so like Mockler,
like for even the things that I think he shouldn't have conceded,
at the end of the day, I think he did well and I think that he's
going to a lot more people in that audience than he would have.
We're not going to see immediate reactions. We're not going to
see like a litany of people going to Twitter saying, you know
what, Mockler, you you changed my mind. People still have egos.
People don't want to admit that they're wrong or their figurehead
is wrong. But through that activity, more people that operate
that way, we're going to get more of those folks. >> Let
me let me ask you something. Like when when you see Hassan have
those kind of interactions with Libs and go into those spaces,
do you do you treat him in good faith? Like do do you think he
is showing up to those conversations in good faith? >> I
do not think Hassan is like some uh revolutionary dude who's
going who's secretly trying to >> Does does Hutch not know
anything about Lyken? He would never ask that question sincerely
if he knows anything about Lyken.
if he knows who Ly is in a relationship with. It's like, "Hey,
I'm going to use the same tactics that are being used against
your partner on Hassan." Are you cool with that? Are you just
going to totally concede that right now? Are you going to Hey,
Lyan, do you want to like totally throw your partner on the bus
by like accepting this whole narrative that basically if you're
a communist, you're a Marxist Leninist who wants to overthrow
violently the US government and all property owners. Hey, Lyan,
do you want to do that right now? Yeah. Good one, Hutch. Good
one. >> Get us into a point of >> It's not It's not
It's not secret though. is he's not secret. >> No, no,
what I mean is like he's acting in those conversations. >> He
has to definitionally be secretive about it because he says I'm
not a Marxist Leninist.
Definitionally, he's being secretive. So, there's one clip where
Hassan says somebody in his chat is like ribbing him over some
leftist and he's like, "Fuck, can I can I find this clip? I don't
know if I was linked on this. Hold on. I'll try to find this
clip from this guy. Somebody linked me this clip and I should
pull it up here. Here, here. Here. Here. This this clip right
here was the one I got. find a more appropriate and more successful
method of of uh
building a Marxist Leninist Vanguard party. I'm going to keep
doing what I'm doing. Okay? And you do you do you. If you build
it, I'll be there by your side. You understand?
>> And try it. >> So like that is kind of implying
that but that's kind of implying that he could be sympathetic
to Marxist Leninist or something, right? But to me, he's kind
of just saying, "Stop criticizing me and [__] off."
I So, you have to weigh this against him explicitly saying, "I
am not a Marxist Leninist,
right?
This is their best clip." I think this is the best clip. I mean,
there's another one. Hold on. This This one. Give me a second.
There's this one. >> That I don't know why he thinks that.
My audience is going to be like, "Wow, this is a bridge too far.
What's next? Are you going to say that you have Marxist Leninist
tendencies? How dare you?"
>> first then being called >> Yeah. All that happened
on that DP program episode is that they were thanking him for
not punching left shooting excessively on revolutionaries. Oh,
okay. I'm I'm just saying like all of this could kind of make
sense, right?
All this can kind of make sense. And yeah, it's like he tries
to make space for these people and that's probably like the the
criticism should be he is too sympathetic to Marxist Leninism,
right? He's too sympathetic. He doesn't think like people who
think that are evil and I think people who think that are evil.
That's your disagreement. Not he is that thing. Not he is that
evil. It's he's too sympathetic. He's too he would be like the
dumb what do you call it? He's a revisionist Marxist Lenist if
I recall correctly. That's what he said. Well, I thought it was
Yeah, I I thought it was revisionist. But revisionist implies
that like you are not violent, right? And when people say Marxist
Lenist, I had this whole argument with people. But when people
say Marxist Leninist, it's implying that you're you're looking
for a revolutionary change. You are willing to to go to violence
for revolutionary for like a revolution to revolt. Yeah. Yeah.
Yeah. Okay. Cuz
Yeah. Okay. All right. Maybe I just don't know. I don't know
enough about this to defend it, but like I'm I'm hearing like
different things. Revisionist or not ML? I don't Okay. I don't
know. It's not super consequential. I just I laugh because it's
like I do know I've seen him say I'm not a Marxist Leninist.
I've seen him say like I don't I don't believe in that. I'm a
revisionist. Right.
So anyway,
>> who's secretly trying to to get us into a point of uh
what do you call it? It's not it's not secret though. It's not
he's not secret. >> No, no. What I mean is like he's acting
in those conversations. >> So that is all to say that you
basically have to argue he's secretive. You can't say he's not
secretive. Also, when he says he's not secretive,
I know for a fact Hutch has to be referring to the Deprogram
podcast. He's not secretive. He says he's secretive,
right? Like like that's what they say from the D program is,
"Oh, he's really secretive. He hides his power level." You say,
"He's not secretive. He told us directly that he's secretive."
Thank you. Thank you, Hutch. >> In way calmer a fashion
towards a liberal than a lot of the streams. That's your point,
right?
>> Um I I I'm saying >> do I think he's acting in
good faith when he does that? >> I mean like presenting
himself honestly and engaging in those spaces honestly. >> Yeah,
I do. >> No, absolutely not. I don't know why you would
think that. That's insane to me because I think he's very very
very very open about what he's trying to do. I don't have you
ever seen Have you ever listened to his appearance on like he
went on a podcast called Deeprogram and >> that's dude
with with the whole thing about the education camps. I did and
then I watched the entire thing around that segment and it was
not as bad as everyone kept saying it was. >> Wait, what?
Okay. Well, >> someone is noting.
>> By the way, uh with these clips, you probably would
want to back it up and see the things that were being said like
the message he's responding to and Right. I didn't do that. Can
you watch the deprogram episode? Maybe at some point. Yeah. But
I'm just I'm laughing. Okay.
I'm laughing. I'm laughing. I'm >> Education camps. But
yeah, if you just say education, >> that was the conversation
that convers Okay, that's
one you brought up before, was it not? >> That's a conversation
with Ethan. I'm talking about a conversation he had when he I
mean, this is not the only
podcast. It's a >> Oh, Lyan's thinking about the the babies,
the baby settlers or something, right? So, like I was talking
about
and there's like a it's like a cartoon like overlay like animated
kind of like does. Yeah. >> Yeah. Like I listen to that
and he talks
>> uh I literally listened to it after Hutch linked it
to him here and it doesn't say what he thinks. Okay, hold on.
By the way, I this is the thing is I just find there's like a
lot of space in there's been a lot I feel like I would open up
paint, but I'm just going to try to but unfortunately other people
think that's a problem. So, I'm going to see I'm going to I'm
going to uh surrender to the mob here and not open up paint and
cuz it wouldn't actually be helpful. I'm going to try to explain
this concept. When I cover Hassan, I see it as like opinion has
shifted so crazily against Hassan that in my head I just get
to go and I basically argue with people that Hassan is not Hitler,
not looking to like kill everybody, not looking to undo democracy
in any meaningful way, right? And that he mostly advocates in
favor of things that you would also advocate for. It's like I'm
not advocating that Hassan's a good person or good has good politics.
I literally just advocate that he's basically not evil, right?
And there's a huge lane of like basically because public opinion
has shifted so much that I could just go and be like, "No, I'm
pretty sure he's not evil." And then people come in and argue
and they look silly. They look very silly like the whole time.
Um, now I will say I probably argued a little too close to the
sun on the I think basically his statements on the October assaults,
but it was just it was more that I should have just said I'm
not going to comment on that until I see the clips.
Right.
I think I've once argued a little too close on that one. And
I do think he Hassan has a problem where he will lean way too
far into the thing he thinks is like basically he'll say like
I'm on the right side and he will lean way too far into arguments
he makes around
oh what would you say like something he ideologically believes
in like he thinks Israel's committing a genocide and so he will
defend things even I think probably against his own opinion sometimes
like he'll just reflexively defend almost anything around being
anti-Israel he'll reflexively defend it if he looks into it he
will come to the correct opinion, but he will reflexively defend
every single time laughing at victims. I don't think he laughed
at victims, dog. I know. I know that's how you see it. I just
don't think that's what it is. I think that's like I think that's
another thing where you look kind of silly to be honest with
you. Right. You're talking about the DNC clip. I defended him
on the DNC clip the second it happened when I was still in DGG.
I think everybody who tried to run that narrative is
it's very depressing. Okay.
multiple. Okay, you're definitely talking about the DNC clip.
You're definitely laughing. Talking about the DNC clip where
he looks looks down and grimaces because he can't believe that
they're doing the thing cuz he thinks he thinks when people focus
on that instead of the genocide, they're essentially just trying
to It's the same as when when you're reasoning for like
there's there's like a primary issue that should have most of
your focus and basically people will try to emotionally signal
to secondary issues to get your focus off the primary issue.
So they'll they'll constantly say, "Oh my god, Hamas did instead
of talking about like the conditions in in Gaza and how bad things
are getting in Gaza, right? That's like the point Hassan's trying
to make when he like grimaces when he's upset about that, right?
That's the point he's trying to make. Now, I think he he goes
too far in that stuff sometimes and he sounds really stupid.
I'll give you that. Okay.
The worst one. Yeah, Missy, I don't know if you watch my sarking
coverage, but I always correct people to that is the worst clip.
That's the worst clip by far. I don't know if you're getting
that opinion on your own or if you're getting that for me, but
that's the one I always bring up. I'm like, that's the one that
sounds the worst. And you can tell he's like angry and it's like
a quippy moment, but it still it's a bad thing to say. You know
what I'm saying? You know what I'm saying? Okay. Anyway, I need
to pull up this this uh Hutch tweet. Give me a second here.
Yeah. So anyway, I like I was saying, my whole thing is I basically
see there's like a massive lane of over criticism of Assan from
like very dumb people that use it to get away with very dumb
things. And I basically just I get to go and like reap the rewards
of being the guy who's like, "Yeah, I don't think Assan's quite
as bad as Hitler, actually. Yeah, I think Hassan's like a little
better than Trump. Yeah, I think Hassan's a little better than
Epstein." Sorry. I'm And you might think that sounds hyperbolic,
but that is unironically like all of my Hassan defense coverage
is basically, yeah, I think Hassan's probably better than Epstein.
Yeah, I think Hassan's probably better than Hitler. Yeah, I think
Hassan's probably better than Trump. Um, so defensive of Hassan,
I guess. So, it's like that's that's quite literally where it
goes. And it's just like, well, there's a bunch of free real
estate there to just do commentary and invite people on or invite
people to talk who are pretty crazy about this and it's just
fun. So anyway, that's my thoughts on defending Hassan. Okay,
I'm willing to defend him up until the point of Epstein at minimum.
Okay, maybe even further. I might even argue that like he's better
than Gain Maxwell. It's crazy. There's more free real estate
on Hutch's dome. Well, yeah, the Hutch Hutch stuff is about what
it uh always boils down to. Hold on, I didn't grab the tweet.
Whoops. Here we go. Around 35 minutes of his one of his debrogram
appearances is when they start talking about his ultimate goal.
The ultimate goal. And Assange talks about pushing for social
democratic policies as a stepping stone to more revolutionary
attitudes. He is not shy about his motives in this video. But
like that's do you understand that is
now you might say okay these guys are like evil. These guys are
evil and they shouldn't be talked to. So again I'm going to say
that's Hassan being too kind to these people. That's your criticism.
It's not that he agrees with them. It's that he is doing what
I think you should do which is you have overlap in what you want.
Hey, you guys like you guys want revolution. Well, don't you
think if we like did a bunch of like socialist policy
um uh what do you call it? Socialist if we pass a bunch of socialist
policies or social safety net policies and people saw their lives
improve massively. Don't you think that would like be a stepping
stone to more revolutionary attitudes trade deal? You guys vote
for us and and then we get it's a stepping stone to more revolutionary
attitudes, right? I assume that's what it is. So, let's go. 35
minutes of this. Let's check it out. What is it? 35 minutes.
>> Hello, dear listener. The American Dream classical story.
I I I had a similar one just a bit more sped up. I did one of
those work and travel programs, etc., etc., and just for 4 months
of >> That's how they should feel if they are further left.
Well, but that's what I'm I'm saying to you guys. I think that's
what Hutch should be doing with like Hassan and Hassan's audience
is like, "Hey, we're trying to pass like some improvement to
Medicare or we're like trying to get Medicare for all pass. I
think it's really important you guys do go out and vote, especially
if you live somewhere like like some kind of red state. It's
really important you go and vote and like you could do outreach.
You're like, "Hey, where's that candidate in the primary who's
supporting like socialized medicine? Show me the candidate in
a primary in a purple state who's supporting socialized medicine.
I'll bring them on my stream. I'll advocate for them. I'll say,
"Hey, tell me your policies. I'll get their name out there as
best I can." Right? It's so easy to build bridges with these
people.
It's so easy to build bridges and just try to get them on your
side in any way. It's like, and I think Hassan's argument might
be the best argument to do that with like the far-lefty types,
right? The the actual MLS and stuff. Hey, don't you think if
we started passing some more policies that that Republicans are
explicitly saying are socialist and people saw their lives improve,
wouldn't that sort of like lead to possibly
like more revolutionary? Oh, actually this whole thing as we
like start to tax people more, get more social safety nets, like
our lives are actually getting better. Oh, this might be
right right.
I I think and by the way, I I could make arguments against that
too on a political basis, but it's like you're trying to get
them to vote for you. You're trying to get them to support you.
experiencing the American dream that I I believed was uh you
know completely achievable in every single corner of the world
just because as we previously talked uh you know over here where
I'm at we still you know have the socialist brain because of
the commies that came before or we're like you know just culturally
inferior we need to become more like the the the Yanks and so
on and so on. Uh but then I went and
>> I just closed it. God damn it. achievable in every single
corner of the world. The socialist break. But then I went and
actually saw it and >> Okay, one second. I'll be right
back. >> And with him, he didn't have to go anywhere. The
Yanks came to him. >> It came to me. >> Yeah, it
came to him. American dream came to his doorstep. >> Exactly
right. >> And then it made a lot of people dream but forever
if you know what I mean. >> Exactly right. Yeah. That's
I think that's the most interesting aspect in the difference
between radicalization
when you're at the uh like at the end of the rifle of American
imperialism or just American foreign policy and when you're behind
it when you see the soldiers when you see the bombs and all this
kind of stuff you are at first filled with like this severe or
just hatred of of the United States and everything it stands
for and then afterwards you take a step back and you you analyze
you're like wait hold on like Joe from like Philadelphia who's
on his third job [laughter] like this week. Um, that guy is not
the guy who who I'm angry at. I'm angry at a different set of
people. And then you you get into class analysis and then that's
when everything kind of comes together. But it's a lot more office
gazed. I can imagine when you're in the United States whether
you've moved to the US or you know you're born there uh because
you don't see this as directly and you're lied to so much from
like the day you're born. So yeah. >> Yeah. That's >> I'm
interested in hearing I don't know if you guys have discussed
this before, but I'm interested in hearing what JT's uh uh analysis
of this is or his radicalization of this is because, you know,
look in in some ways I think all three of us and our perspective
on the United States of America
is, you know, it's obvious, right? But for someone to be born
in the United States, to be to grow up in the United States and
then to have uh shared values like this in a country that is
disseminating the most red scare propaganda that has so effectively
shut out any kind of class consciousness.
Um I think that is even a really really terrible time stamp from
Hutch but okay >> to do. >> Yeah. I mean for me it
was pretty
It's cool to hate Hassan now. Hutch is trying to be the cool
guy, but he's never going to be that. I think it's like rapidly
becoming uncool to hate Hassan. At least to the degree people
do.
You can dislike the guy. There's like I'm totally fine being
like, "This guy's cringe. This guy this guy sucks. He's like
a socialist, but he wears really expensive clothes." Like, that's
all surface level and whatever.
It's fine if you want to make those critiques. If you actually
believe that, I don't give a [__] Right.
Hassan would be like, "Yeah, I wear I wear cringe clothes, but
also I don't think that cuts against my beliefs or something,
right?" And then you're having like a real argument.
You're just having a real argument then. But when you're like
trying to build it up to like Hassan's trying to overthrow the
US government, it's like, "No, I'm pretty sure he's not, man.
I just Hassan is bad. I'm pretty sureization process." You know,
Bernie came around and I was like, "Oh, wow. He's saying stuff
I haven't heard before." Yeah. Why is our healthcare so expensive?
Stuff like that. And you know, you know how it goes. I would
I I would I heard the rhetoric like, "Oh, he's not actually a
socialist. He's a a social democrat." I'm like, "Okay, >> Oh,
I Oh, you guys are talking about Emma Vigland, dude. H I do not
like Emma Vigland. I'm not a fan of Emma Vigland. I feel like
that might be where the line is. I watched her argument with
um Jesse
The whole the the criticisms they had of Jesse Singal.
I man I cannot I cannot with them. Okay. Yeah, I can difference
between social democracy and socialism and then I'd >> you
know read a little bit more about that. Um and then the the turning
point for me was when I picked up State and Revolution and read
that and then this things started to coll.
>> Oh yeah, it's amazing. For anybody who hasn't read State
and Revolution, it's short. It's easy to read. It's >> like
I'm sorry. You know what the criticism of this is so far?
This is boring. I hate this. Why would you watch this? >> Stood
stood to the test of time really quite well. He's a funny guy.
Like London's sassy. I love it. Um [laughter] but um but that
yeah, that was it was an interesting process because you know
a lot of Americans, myself included, were by default kind of
Hutch is soping my stream. He's like watch from 35 minutes onwards.
It's literally a conversation about why they believe in communism.
I don't what what what
huh what what are we proving here? >> Uh apolitical in
that it doesn't really affect us very much. You might dislike
conservatives depending on where you live because they're, you
know, loud and obnoxious and and racist and all that stuff. And
so you've got a gut reaction, negative re reaction against that.
But that doesn't mean that, you know, you consider yourself political.
And I was I was that way. But it's really hard to >> I
this over I left that on one X. Okay, that was me. That was information
here in the US when everything from our textbooks to like children's
shows to, you know, sitcoms as you grow up to the news to movies,
blockbuster movies, it's all so steeped in anti-communist
>> I I guess I can't say, but I feel like Canada and the
US's education systems aren't that far apart. They're they're
like reasonably far apart. They're not like crazy far apart.
Do you guys really get like a ton of Red Scare propaganda in
like kindergarten? Is that a thing? Like I'm sure if the if the
propaganda is like h communism must be communism is I'm sure
like communism is a thing that people say
>> you know even to this day and it's so you have this
ingrained cultural um revulsion or fear of anything that is seen
as unamerican and that term has been so heavily conflated with
leftwing economics, leftwing politics. I mean, properly leftwing,
socialist and beyond. >> Every movie I know Russians were
like the big bad for a long time. Thank God for No, I know. I
Oh, I almost said something crazy. Uh I I said thank God and
then listen to what I'm going to say next and you'll know where
I was going. That was crazy. Okay. But like it seemed like you
know 911 happened and then the Arabs got to be the big bad. Okay.
And then Russia got people let off of the communists when it
was the uh when the after 911. Okay.
I would never say the I would never say the other party. What
do you mean? The Democrats are I thought they were communist.
What the >> By the way, I don't actually think that either.
I'm just laughing cuz I I was going to say like, "Oh, thank God
something happened so that we got to shift off of the communist
propaganda or something, but it's not like I don't thank God
that that >> Yeah, this this morning now they've they've
arrested their their political rival Donald Trump. We were living
in communist America. >> Yeah, I don't get it. >> Exactly
right. >> It's when the government does stuff." >> It's
it's very it's interesting. thing. It's frustrating and it's
why I made my channel the way I did when I when I you know, not
to sound. >> No, 911 is the perfect example of why terrorism
against citizens doesn't work. Like literally the it's literally
the prototypical example of why terrorism against citizens can't
work. It's like it's basically when you feel like you're and
you're just being like um you're just getting retribution, right?
That's all it is. It's not like um it's not an effective mechanism.
It doesn't really do anything. It is quite literally just retribution
for retribution's sake. It's not going to help anybody. It's
in fact it's going to hurt people, but you want to, you know,
you want to feel that momentary elation you get out of hurting
the other person. Same thing with October 7th, right? I understand
why it happened. I think um it was inevitable, but at the same
time, October 7th was obviously going to lead to like horrible
outcomes for those people.
Is America worse or better since? Why do you think that has anything
to do with um the wars or
or the actual attack? It definitely did not start a slow collapse.
Actually, it definitely did not.
That's a I'm I'm very shocked that this could be an opinion.
I'm going to go ahead and say that the actual thing that really
[__] people over was probably like right after that,
right? It was probably the mortgage crisis.
Like that was probably the actual thing that [__]
people over. Like that's probably actually what's leading more
so to systemic collapse is is a financial system that it's increasingly
like bilking people out of their money.
to me >> or anything, but like when I had my eyes open
to the reality of of how the United States actually works >> where
the people who operate that financial system are inc totally
insulated from risk, all of the risk is is offset to the American
people. I'd say that's probably a bigger deal. >> I was
like, okay, how would I have wanted this explained to me when
I was first learning about this stuff and so that's why I took
the 101 approach
>> uh yeah, you absolutely do get Trump without the war
on terror. You don't understand American politics. This is really
rough, really rough to listen to these messages. >> The
average American has it's not just that they're starting from
square one.
30. You have to first pick apart all of the things that have
been programmed into them and then you can start to build upon
a a basis of reality. >> You're describing the reason why
so many people simultaneously consider me to be a Democratic
party mouthpiece or a suck or whatever the but also a threat
to America as well because I I do just like
>> uh I I'll pull up I'll pull up that Emma Viglin Jesse
Singal call right now and I will I will react to that in front
of you boy and destroy your idol. Okay. I will snark Emma Viglland
so hard you will not be able to watch the majority report ever
again. Okay. Never threaten >> Like you said, I do advocate
for social democratic reforms and I do think that in order to
develop any kind of mechanism of push back, a robust labor force
that has uh any kind of, you know, speaking power, any kind of
fighting power to strike at uh the heart of the the Imperial
Corps where value is generated. I I think that in the short term
in order to combat against that you you have to advocate for
a much lighter form of of propaganda despite you know I perfectly
understand that social democracies uh benefit tremendously from
uh American imperialism, western imperialism and and would not
exist in the way that they do without such atrocities committed.
Right? But, you know, if you want America, in the way that I
feel about it, and if you want America to get out of the way
for uh places with more revolutionary potential to do what they
would normally do, I think that, you know, one thing you have
to do is is advocate for a a lighter form while simultaneously
still doing agitated propaganda that goes beyond uh, you know,
right Democratic ideas. >> I just wanted to like put emphasis
on the exact point of the so-called
So again, I guess this all comes out it all comes down to like
how much charity you want to grant Hassan because I think it's
I see both worlds. I think mine's way more likely the one where
he's trying to explain to these people why they should be basically
supporting these social democratic policies. Right? Hassan's
here to advocate for social he's here to sell social democracy
to tankies. That's what Hassan's doing it
Sorry. That's what Hassan's doing right now to me. He's going
to sell social democracy to tankies. Hey, if you're a tanky,
you should support what I'm doing because here's how it helps
you,
right? This is what a salesperson does.
Hey, the thing I wanted to do is actually good for you. Hey,
the thing I want to do is actually good for you, too. Right?
At least, and by the way, he is a revisionist Marxist or whatever.
He does believe in getting to the place they want to get to,
right? And he's like, "Listen, I think I think my way will win,
but my way actually will probably help you get your way, too."
like we both win but I think I think my way is the way to go
anywayization funnel where for example Hassan and JT catch them
while they're young as they say uh and then they start looking
into this uh new idea etc etc and then move forwards through
the funnel get more and more informed get more and more radicalized
and so on can
>> we might do this Junar if you want to grab some links
for this I'll cover this um tomorrow
um
I yeah I'll cover this tomorrow for sure Hassan getting so out
Taiwan. This is the one place where I'm like, "Yeah, these are
harmful attitudes."
I don't want anybody to be
I and I know I trust me, this is going to be fighting the tide
because I know a lot of people uh a lot of these beliefs go hand
in hand with believing that like China number one.
China number one. Oh, Taiwan number one. Okay. and absolutely
utilize the stuff that Hassan does because Hassan does one very
particular thing that
social democrats that we would never call this podcast
because they they they cut the funnel from both sides. But what
do I mean by this? They introduce people to you know lukewarm
socialist ideas. >> Did we get the do we get the thing?
>> And then they from Democrats that we would never call
to this podcast or we would give a little [__] to
because they they they they cut the funnel from both sides. What
what do I mean by this? They introduce people to you know lukewarm
socialist ideas etc et
[laughter] is is this guy is this is a basically calling Hassan
out directly
and then they want to keep him there right well whenever Hassan
introduces people to socialist ideas yes the the lukewarm not
so scary sounding uh >> oh okay it's the yuggabnik guy
but the yuggabnik guy is calling Hassano directly I wonder if
Hassan gets hostile with him at all wait I should always know
who who is if I'd ever heard heake speak and knew he was from
Iraq. I would have known Nero was from Iraq immediately. Nero
and Hakee sound exactly alike.
It's very funny. Like they're the same exact same voice, exact
same accent. I don't know how that turns into the Iraqi accent.
It doesn't make any sense to me, but they have the exact same
accent. Anyway, okay. The Yugobnic guy calling >> keeping
your power levels low hidden and so on and so on. Uh he does
not stop them from progressing through the funnel and getting
additional and additional information and so on. He doesn't agitate
against for example the the revolutionary perspective and so
on and so on. That is the the main the main difference. You know
you do your part >> that was a shout out to Hassan that
like you're different from other people who will acknowledge
some of these socialist ideals acknowledge some of the stuff
but then you will straight up say like but don't listen to anybody
further away from me cuz those people they're crazy. That's they're
saying thank you for not doing that.
Which is funny because if you've ever watched
Hassan actually does do that a lot. Every time there's a bad
empanada fan and Hassan's chat being like, "You don't understand
the theory on this. You're not up to speed." Hassan crashes the
out. GET THE [__] OUT OF HERE. GO BACK TO BAD EMPANADA.
CRASHES. Do you remember him watching the Platiner stuff and
and some some bad empanada fan comes in and explains why Platner
is bad and Hassan like absolutely crashes out on the guy. It's
so funny. It's so funny, dude. Here's the clip. Yeah, I got it.
Um, I'm just It's probably not a part of the segment. I I try
not to get too disconnected from the current segment so that
it all like works better if it end ever ends up going to YouTube.
Trying not to get too disconnected. Okay, go back to the Hutch
thing right now. We might We might watch some of this, too. We'll
see if there are any good clips here. Okay, we'll see if there
are any good clips from the Dan stream on this afterwards, but
right now we're watching. >> That's about it. It even says
like, you know, I know people like like they hear, you know,
reeducation and they think like reeducation camps and that's
not what I'm talking about. >> That was the one on that
was Ethan. That was a conversation I had with Ethan.
>> you said that the one on the deprogram podcast, they
had a whole conversation about the process of like the intentional
process of trying to radicalize people. So, they have like a
conversation for about 10 minutes where they talk about their
radicalization and they're talking about radicalization as a
uh essential part of um someone's like political evolution. They're
saying like a radical radicalization against like western imperialism
and capitalism is basically what they're going with. And um the
host of the podcast um kind of tease up Assan and even though
the host and and the other guys second thought they're much more
kind of directly confrontational kind of explicitly radical um
Hassandro contrast with them by talking about his approach uh
to to radicalizing people as like introducing them via policies
that are you could call like social democratic but he talks about
social democratic policies as though they're bad things. He talks
about social democracy as in a in a bad kind of way. But the
point is, >> no, he says something true that you don't
like. Like
this would be this is totally seeding. This is functionally in
an abstract sense the exact same argument as saying, "Well, yeah,
you say America's great, but you also say it was built on slavery.
So you're America, aren't you?" Well, no, America was built like
the economy was originally built on slavery. Like that's just
a fact. and ignoring that fact or lying about that fact is kind
of [__] up. Like you should acknowledge that you
maybe don't have to spend all of your time on it like constantly
heranging yourself over it. But that's what Hassan's doing there,
right? He's like, I like social democratic policies and I do
know that you know Sweden, Norway, these countries probably don't
exist in a non
uh like a non US
hegemonic world where where US imperialism is like dominated
everything makes global trade possible. every no country has
to have a military. Like yes, we we probably
we we probably need to acknowledge that that like u that these
social democratic policies only work in places that are already
given peace by the imperial like
power, right? I think that's that's what he's trying to do. Yeah,
we did reconstruction. Well, hold on. I'm I'm trying to explain
to you that Hassan is acknowledging uh like a downside of the
thing that's probably true that in a like in a non-dominated
world, in a multipolar world or a just a chaotic world, those
social democratic places don't necessarily work, right? They
might not be able to take their budgets and focus entirely on
their population,
right?
But that's that's
And he's just saying he's cutting off an argument from them is
like, well, you're you're arguing you're arguing for something
halfway and we need full revolution because actually the world
can never be free as long as we're under cap the capitalist boot
or whatever the [__] they're going to say, right?
That's that's what I think that's what they're going to say is
what their argument would be back >> is to like >> Yeah.
Yeah. Yeah. And they participate in the global economy. They
Yeah. Like I But that's all true. Like especially when you when
you look at the the world through this frame that's all true
that we all benefit from like exploitation of of different populations.
We all benefit from it, right? This is the Vosch. If you buy
a computer, you're basically a argument, okay? That like you
actually if you if you buy computer parts, you actually really
can't look down on
you're you're actually taking advantage of child labor. You're
actually taking advantage of child slavery. Is child slavery
significantly worse than child. Okay? It's that whole argument,
that whole line of argumentation, okay? Like hook them with,
you know, like, hey, we want to give you free healthcare and
we want to give you like paid family leave and these kind of
things. And then once you have them hooked, you radicalize them
further into an explicitly illiberal ideology. Like he is not
shy >> Yeah, that's his plan. But like my argument has
always been like, >> "Oh, this is like this is such a lazy
analysis.
It's just so lazy. It's not looking at things." Dude, it's just
>> wait hold on. He has a conversation with um like maybe
the pod save guys or um uh or Adam Mockler or or a lot like a
bunch of other like central life platforms. He'll describe himself
as like a progressive and he'll talk about the Democratic party
in terms of like we like he includes himself like we you know
like we the Democratic party and then he'll go into other spaces
and then on his own stream he'll have a completely different
tone when he's talking about the Democratic party. He talks about
the Democratic party on his stream when he's by himself as though
they are you know an exp like an opposition party >> and
so like there's like there's a term for what he's >> I
mean that is that is talking to the room. I don't I I've definitely
seen him talk about the Democratic party is in we like other
times. I do know what Hutch is saying, right?
But almost it it probably depends on what criticisms you have,
how far the Democrats are away from your like ideal and then
probably you're going to talk about the problems you have and
and think of them more as another the further away they are from
your ideal. But that doesn't mean you don't go to people like
like realistically
and again I'll just say like I wonder if he would have the same
argument for counterpoints because I'm sure Counterpoints talks
about the Democratic party as an opposition, right?
I feel like he almost certainly would talk about them that way.
Like there like they do things I don't like. And so I'm wondering
what the I guess I guess it's probably the more foundational
like principled commitment to disavowing anybody who's against
illiberalism, right? that that does make sense in Hutch's worldview
that he could probably go to counterpoints more than Hassan.
Hassan does have some illiberal tendencies in that he is not
intolerant to people with illiberal ideas.
So I think you can get there with the argument. It's just a much
softer version of the argument they use. Like you could have
Hutch's position that Hassan is sympathetic to people with totally
illiberal views. That is that is pretty inarguable, right? He
is sympathetic to those people. I do not believe that he himself
has those views. And I do believe that if you're purity testing
on just sympathies, you end up reducing your tent by a lot.
So anyway, >> doing it's a term that is like >> so
is Connor. Absolutely true actually, Missy. Fantastic point.
So is Connor. I'll vote for JD Vance. I'd vote for JD Vance over
AOC. >> Like rooted in um like socialist literature. It's
called entryism. >> Yeah. But like I I don't I don't subscribe
to that because at the end of the day, we this is this is the
issue I have. We hold the power. Like we are the party, we are
the power. We are the liberals, right? There is no amount of
leftists that exists to usurp us with that. What does, >> you
know, arguing with them on merit misses the point. I know arguing
with people on merit almost all of the time misses the point.
It doesn't mean I don't want to be able to make the merit-based
argument. I think I think I only want to argue people I will
only argue with people in a way that is like not on the merits.
That is like basically pointing out that they're bad faith or
something. If I know I'm gonna win on the merits,
I never want to risk going into an argument where I disagree
with somebody and I I don't have like solid feet under my ground
or sorry, solid ground under my feet. Solid feet under my ground.
I'm not getting pulled down into the ground. Okay? I never want
to go into conversation like that and then they actually try
to fight me on the merits and I get blown out. I don't want that
to ever happen. So, I always try to make sure I can make the
argument on the merits. That's why I try to do it. You know what
I'm saying? That's the whole point. That's what this is all about.
does exist is >> like I'm totally fine using other tactics
if I have to, but I I want to know that I'm fighting for something
that I believe on its merits first.
>> Need to to some degree um cater and our overton window
maybe needs to move a little bit or whatever, but to get us to
something that brings these people in. So, if it's these entry
things or whatever, that doesn't matter because at the end of
the day, these people aren't going to serve us. We're going to
be fine. Like, the Liberal Party isn't going away. Uh, >> and
I think we're overindexing for the threat of, you know, the the
leftists in a way that is harmful because we're just like completely
discounting the votes that we need.
>> I mean, you can hold on. I want to give me just a second.
I want to find I want to find a poll to show you. Um,
[__] Where the did I see it? >> Something to
think about.
>> Hey, this
>> Okay, I I can't I can't even remember where to look
for this poll, but I I don't think it would shock you. Um
they did a there's been many many polls about like asking American
voters what they think of the the the parties and what they thought
of like Kla Harris.
It might have been deciding to win that I don't remember but
like if
so we going to start running with this narrative Johnny Bravo
it's a force multiplier multiplier for at least 10% of the force
to be smart. Yeah sure true you need this the smart friend who
can explain things to you. >> Got to guess >> the
the general >> what percentage of the country overall across
independents, Republicans, Democrats thought that Kla Harris
was um too conservative?
>> What percent thought she was too
>> Uh I don't know 5% maybe 10%. >> It was about
5%. Yeah. It I think it was I think it was less. I think there
was like 4%. And if you had to guess like what percentage of
the country thought Kla Harris was too liberal?
>> Oh, but this isn't this is like missing the point. The
reason people think Camala Harris is too liberal is because she
had the most liberal voting record as a senator of all her contemporaries
in the Senate. That's just factual. Saying she's even if you
think she's too conservative on Gaza, if you said you thought
she's too conservative, you're you're like an actual she's like
the most progressive in terms of the policies she's tried to
put forward, in terms of the policies she's tried to support.
She's the most progressive candidate for president ever by a
lot. If you're like she's too conservative, you're like,
okay. Yeah, she panned hard on the trans stuff. She was all over
the place doing the most progressive stuff during like right
before CO and during CO. She was doing this stuff all over the
place.
Why are we Why are we crazy? Yeah. Yeah. Like I I watched um
like this is an analysis that 538 Nate Silver would always do
is like what was your Senate voting record? What was your voting
record like? And then they would chart out the the primary candidates.
And it's like Kla Harris had I believe she had a slightly more
progressive voting record than Bernie Sanders because she would
vote for progressive policy on immigration. She would propose
or support progressive policy on immigration too. And Bernie
was a bit of a hawk on immigration before he ran his first candidacy,
right? Or even I think even to his second one a little bit he
was more of a hawk on on immigration. Like I say hawk he was
like opposed to open immigration in a way that Kamla wasn't.
Kamla's from California. A lot of the economy runs on immigration,
right? So I think she had a more progressive voting record than
Bernie Sanders actually on those marginal
>> Like what who like what do you think that looked like?
>> I said marginal issues. I meant like marginally prog
more progressive voting because of the those issues. I misspoke.
>> No, no, it was much higher than that. It was much higher
than that. I think it was a majority. I'm pretty sure it was
like 55 or 60%. Um, so if you're trying to appeal to to me pragmatically,
then why would why I'll be honest with you, I've seen Clement
in like Discords today, so I know he's alive, but I did I message
him. Oh, I didn't message him. I was going to say I thought I
messaged him, but I didn't message him. I was going to say he
I don't think he responded to me the last time, but I was going
to message him to play WoW or something today, and I don't think
I messaged him. So, that's my bad.
I think he said he was planning to be back like for the weekend,
but I think he's I think he might need the weekend now or something.
I don't know. I I say that because he's not back for the
He He'll let you know. >> Party not aggress. >> He's
just testing his audience, okay? He'll let you know. All right.
I know some of you guys are here hoping he'll be around or would
say something. I'm I I don't think that's going to happen, but
he'll let you know, okay? When you need to know. Otherwise, just,
you know, stand back and stand by. ly court um independents,
voters in the center, you know, it's hard to define these terms.
They're a little bit murky these days,
these guys why would why would the Democratic party get like
spend all this time and resources and energy going
>> um I'm not talking about represent% of the country.
>> Did they have an impact on 2024 or not? That's why if
they did, that's why. If they didn't, then yeah, ignore them,
>> dude. Oh, bad empota is out of his mind, dude. I'm sorry.
I find this funny in a dark humor kind of way. Not actually not
actually avowing it. I'm just sorry. It's like an insane thing
to say. This guy's totally out of his mind. Elely waiting for
the names of the dead American soldiers so I can DM their family
on social. Dude, this guy's out of his mind. That I totally disavow
that. That guy's crazy and ugly. Am I >> guy's crazy?
>> Totally disavowing. >> Oh, whoops. Whoops. Wrong
wrong thing here. Totally totally disavow that. I just Bro, the
guy's out of his mind. Okay. This is totally crazy. Well, this
is something that is like up for debate. Um, but the idea that
like you don't need to assign full blame to this group of people
in order to criticize them. Like if they didn't vote for Karma,
>> if they didn't >> Don't pull Don't pull that up.
I'm going to pull that up. I I could I could sincerely disavow
that. Obviously, I do think it's a joke, but
uh not even as a joke, man. Not even don't even don't even do
it as a joke. >> Vote for Kamala. But but they weren't
the sole reason. They still contributed to her loss, you know?
Like if if I don't know why like Nuome would even think about
spending a dime trying to go after those people who saw everything
that Donald Trump did during his first term and um everything
that he was promising to do
even on Gaza. I mean like he was very >> not a joke I disavow
either way >> in the open saying I'm just going to let
Israel just do whatever the >> A lot of a lot of the Hassan
fans are here advocating for the same policy that HASSAN DOES.
BAN ALL FANS BAN THEM ALL NOW. [__] they want to
do >> which say what you will about Biden that was not
his policy >> I'm pretty sure we don't have any sincere
bad empanada fans here at best we have like um queen fans that
lar is loving anybody who is like transgressive the more transgressive
the more they love them okay with no no ability to defend that
love they just are like I love it when people are mean and like
evil on the internet that's like the that's at best what we got
here okay I think he was >> he's more implicit about it
[laughter] >> well no I mean his administration definitely
influenced Israel and pressured Israel to, you know, do things
like allow humanitarian aid into the region. I mean, that would
not happen. >> A lot of bad [__] had to happen
and it took way too long. >> That's not true, though. >> That
is not No, no, no. That's not true, though. Like, I'm saying
in the earliest [clears throat] days of that conflict, the State
Department went to Israel and they asked them, "Okay, so what
is your plan for allowing humanitarian aid into the region?"
And Israel's response was, "What are you talking about? We're
not going to do that." They initially were telling the State
Department, "We have no plans of letting humanitarian aid into
the country." >> Hold on. I got to Google something. I
can't remember the name of this act. >> Are you going to
talk about like the legaly laws right now? Is that >> it?
Yep. Like
after after the fact like you know after Biden we get all away
from my point >> No my point is that there that like the
pressure wasn't enough. We had more pressure that we could have
put on and we didn't. That was the issue. >> I mean I listen
I agree. I don't even disagree with that. >> Okay. Well
that's my whole point is like there was more we could have done
and we we Biden chose not to do it. So while Biden don't disagree,
but I'm just saying like what if if you were someone who was
a pro Palestinian advocate and you heard everything that Donald
Trump was saying very explicitly like that he was going to do.
>> Wait, you're not going to lose me on this. I'm with
you. I'm with you. >> No, I'm not talking about you. I
mean the general you and if you really thought that like if you
really thought that um you know there wasn't going to be much
of a difference I like Newsome should absolutely not spend any
money any time trying to court those people there. there's a
way bigger chunk of people in the country that are not totally
turned off by Democrats but they think they've gone too far in
a number of issues like that that is a way more numerous group
and the problem is is if you spend a lot of time courting the
you know like 4% of the country that think that command was too
conservative well then you are significantly risking you know
perpetuating the sentiment the anti-democratic party sentiment
that people in the center have right now they think the Democrats
are too liberal they think they're too extreme >> who I'm
sorry I I apologize >> on social policy there's a bunch
of people. There's like so much room on economic policy. And
I think the only reason you conflate the two is probably,
in my opinion,
because you want to cut out those other people on the left, on
the far left, right?
Like
if Chank was just less off-putting to the average person, he's
he'd almost have it. He's got like a lot of good instincts. He
just like he implements them in the worst possible ways. He's
like, "Guys, I think we need leftwing economic populism. I'm
going to start talking to MAGA people. It's like, no, shut up.
Stop. Stop. Stop. Stop. You were cooking in the first half. You
lost me in the second half. Okay. Could you just You're almost
there. Who thinks
>> A huge chunk of the country, bro. >> But that's
insane.
>> It doesn't matter. It is what I mean, but it is what
it is. >> Okay. Like, yeah, that perception is insane,
but like where does that perception come from? Like this is actually
something like to me by the way this is new information so I'm
engaging with this like completely neutrally but the idea that
that uh like where does this come from? Like where does this
sentiment come from? Is it trans issues?
>> No, I think it's this is a complex issue I think and
I think it it goes back like decades. Um and I think it has a
lot to do with how organized and wellunded
the right-wing media apparatus is. I mean I can send you here
I just put it in your >> Why you do that? Um, oh, sorry.
I probably have some
>> I'll send I'll send it to you on Discord >> Yeah,
apologies. I had to I don't know how to undo that. It was only
30 >> Just just look at that. Just look at that. Just look
at that. I mean, that's this is like very very relevant to what
we're talking about. >> Voters are very openly saying that
we scold people in virtue signal too much. It's not uh made a
problem. >> No, just look at the just just look at the
the image that I linked. >> Sure. Voters saying each party
is out of touch. Apologies, guys. I don't have it set up so I
can share this with you. Give me a sec. Uh I'll link it in chat
for those who want to follow along. So again, this is going to
be like totally informed by how the conversations are taken,
right? There's like
h it's so it's so gay. It's like this is this is probably going
to be the argument around like when you go to support trans people,
you basically how can I put this? What would be good issue? I
think I think abortion is actually something where Republicans
did the unpopular thing, okay? like in terms of electing conservative
Supreme Court justices that overturned Roie Wade. But it's like
when was Trump when Trump was asked about abortion, he basically
just said he supports abortion, right? Like it's kind of like
that where am I advocating lying for politicians? Probably actually.
Like you probably just need to let some of those don't give people
the clips they need to in the current environment. Don't give
people the clips they need to run against you, right?
So come up, have can statements for this stuff and have can statements
that do not like stick you to a position
Uh because this is the thing is you give people the way the like
first bit
it might even be that you just don't take those conversations
cuz like it it just sucks, right? Like conservatives took basically
I think Democrats moved rightward on the trans youth science
thing quite a bit from 2020 to 2024, right? 2018 to 2024, they
moved rightward quite a bit. They were like no longer advocating
for this like significantly in any way.
But if if Republicans were like, "Oh, you like you support like
people being able to to get their kids healthcare." They give
like a nuance answer sometimes. It's like, "Dude, don't even
give don't even give the nuance answer, right?
Don't do it. Don't do it.
Aren't entitled to the truth?" I think you are entitled to the
truth. I think foundationally democracy doesn't work.
Foundationally, democracy actually doesn't work in the modern
age. People with the ability, people who are more intelligent
than you have more capital and more capacity to sway you than
they ever have before in human history. Democracy fails under
these conditions.
Now, I have no plan for how to fix it. I don't know what you
do. I don't know how you fix it. I really don't. Okay. In the
meantime, it's like politicians need to adapt to the fact that
democracy doesn't work. Unfortunately,
there's like something going on there that it just straight up
doesn't work. You need to take into account the fact that you're
going to be lied about and not give the ammo to other people
to lie about you. Uh enslave I'm not saying, dude, I don't have
a better system. I literally don't have a better system. Socialism
is not even related to this. Socialism is a way of of the economy.
Anyway, um I have no better system than democracy. I'm just saying
the fundamental underlying assumption of democracy is that a
voter can be informed. I think we have categorically disproven
the idea that a voter can be informed.
Okay, the average voter is not informed. I'm not even sure the
average voter has the capacity to be informed. I don't think
education can fix that gap. I think you now have a technological
advantage, a capa, a a capital advantage. You have an advantage
in every possible way over if you are smart and you can literally
just build up some amount of money over your life, right? You
start a company, you will have the capacity to influence people
in a way that nobody else can. you have essentially like it's
a totally asymmetric playing field. It's probably always been
that way, but the the issue is the slant on it is like so much
worse than it's ever been before. It's like there's so many more
players.
It's you know, okay, you think capitalism fails in the same way?
Capitalism fails because you have to earn money now.
Capitalism fails because uh Asmin Gold is a billionaire. capitalism
when capitalism was was producing goods
and not producing entertainment like in in a massive I think
capitalism fails as the amount of capital devoted towards producing
entertainment increases and the amount of capital towards producing
like material goods or making advancements in material science
decreases.
Capitalism starts to fail because human beings will fundamentally
go towards entertainment more than any of the other stuff. they
are incapable of actually making intelligent capital investments
and normally you get that cap that gets captured by intelligent
people who are making things right that capital gets the the
revenues get captured by somebody who's intelligent can make
something but now the revenues get captured by Asminold who's
a inbredad
and he doesn't know how to invest that stuff he probably gives
it to somebody else it's like the the people who actually have
the money are not intelligent enough to to continue to reinvest
that money what do yeah no I'm I'm telling you that the idea
that people will choose the idea of capitalism ism is that people
will excessively like will choose things that advance humanity
forward. And I'm saying we've broken that assumption now as well
that we we no longer prioritize buying things that advance humanity
forward. It's Listen, you say it's I actually don't think it's
now. It's probably not that Asmin Gold holds the capital because
asminold probably is a money manager who who allocates that capital
to things that can make money. But I I under I in an underlying
sense I think this is why if you're going to say that like u
a authoritarian regime might win over America. It could be this.
Okay. Capitalism still works. It still allocates money. Like
if AI is going to work, capitalism is allocating money and investment
to it, right?
But I do think there's something like some amount of inefficiency
here where like the the efficient market hypothesis is starting
to fail in some ways
or the efficient market hypothesis is always basically assumed
that people will spend the most money on things that advance
humanity because they it tends to co it tends to coincide. It's
like an assumption that's sort of decoupling from the the under
the there was an underlying assumption that was included and
it's decoupling from the assumption like efficient markets are
always efficient. They'll always give people what they want,
but what people wanted was basically always the same thing as
what made their lives easier. And now what makes your life easier
is opium. Okay.
Anyway, >> I put it in YouTube chat. I can't use the the
reream chat and share it with everyone. All right, let me read
this.
>> share of voters saying each party is out of touch. 51%
Democrat. >> But that's not No, I actually So, this could
also be a thing, Private Huff, but I don't think that's what
we're experiencing right now. And and listen, it's sort of a
meme. It's like a thought experiment from a friend of mine from
a while like when I was in university or something. So, it's
like a thought experiment from back then that I think is very
interesting and I think it has a tangible effect. It's probably
not like the overriding thing that's making people fail, but
it certainly is.
If nothing else, it's sort of like the grooming thing like when
you when you groom somebody without intention like we were talking
about with the um the people or like Chris Tyson when you're
like or Naku when you're like exposing them to themes and stuff
elements, you're probably sort of like smoothing the the or or
shaving down the guardrails that would have been there that would
prevent them from being taken advantage of in the future. I think
the the shift towards entertainment is doing the same thing with
people that we're sort of we're shaving down the guardrails that
keep us from that that keep us like keep capital investments
working correctly and sorry actually they keep democracy working
because they as you increase this like capacity to want entertainment
to to always fill your life with entertainment all things become
entertainment
to some extent
>> um saying >> cuz they're all they're all competing
ing for your attention. Man, there's probably I need to start
writing stuff down again. I always say that, but I actually do
need to start writing some stuff down and like drawing things
out how I think they work. I'm never going to do that on stream,
though. You always I always look You'll always look doing that
on stream. Click the last thing I linked. What was it? I was
ranting. What was the last thing you linked?
Hold on. Hold on. Hold on. I'm going to roll this back like 15
seconds, too. This isn't, by the way, I don't think I make almost
any of the same criticism socialists make about capitalism. And
I I also think capitalism is still the best system we have until
we can shift to something else.
You guys made him change his banner. Oh
Is his banner no longer Hassan?
What? It's Hutch bitter.
What is this tattoo, bro?
Are these all the
respect existence or expect resistance? Wow. He's pointing at
people and he's making a face. Dude, [laughter] even when he's
taking selfies, he's still like um he's still emoting in the
selfies. >> Like, what? I'm so confused. What? I'm sorry.
It's funny. It's very funny. Okay, we need to get back to those
who want to follow along. Um I put it in YouTube chat. I can't
use the the reream chat and share it with everyone. All right,
let me read this. Um >> share of voters saying each party
is out of touch. 51% Democrat. Um saying each party is out of
touch. Democratic Party 51% Democratic Party >> in 2013.
>> Yeah. 2013
>> 70%. Uh I mean like so but we can discount this is all
>> that was a very that was a Aaron just being a human
right there. That's just Aaron being a human. Totally human
>> human being coming through >> in 2013. Yeah. >> Coming
through >> 70%. Uh >> oh she was giving the she was
Oh, she's flipping the bird to the stream. I see. I thought she
was like waving with her hand not moving for a second. I thought
her hand was the other way. I thought she was like kind of waving.
No, now it's fine. I thought she was like just holding her hand
like in the air like she was royalty. You know how royals like
just hold their hand up and they like kind of turn and angle
it towards the crowd. I thought she was doing that. >> I
mean like
>> but we can discount this is all voters, right? This
isn't Democrats to Democrats, right? This is all voters. like,
you know, if I see that 70%. Am I wrong for saying um yeah, I
don't give a [__] what uh you know, probably 40%
of that of that says at the very least. >> Well, I I don't
think you should be overly concerned that partisan Republican
voters feel feel that way. But this is this um among independents
like if even if you break it down, if you get more granular with
it, and you can find this this data this this trend to be consistent
across multiple surveys that have happened at this point where
uh independ >> Hold on real quick. He's they're talking
about this polling. We will keep listening. But this was the
Hutch is so stupid. I feel like he has to enjoy being humiliated
at this point. This used to be his banner. Wow.
Wow. Wow. Wow. Wow. >> Voters. Like 40% of the country
that are not registered as Democrat or Republican. Um
they have a less favorable view of the Democratic party in this
particular way. Like but they have a higher percentage of them
think that Democrats are out of touch than they think about the
Republican party. And this is a very real problem. It is like
I agree that a lot of it is based on ignorance, propaganda, you
know, right-wing media apparatus just doing its thing and being
really wellunded and you know it's just it is easier to demagogue
than it is to inspire hope. So they have the advantage >> and
I want to know what touch means to these people like how was
it presented to get you know this answer right? >> Well
I mean is this really taking you off guard? Does this >> Yeah,
a little bit. Uh well no not a little bit because again when
I think that like Republicans are included in this I'm like okay
right like half the country is Republicans so you know 70% of
the you know 70% of people uh felt that way it's like way significantly
less in the voter
the Republicans [__] the [__] >> it's
all like narrative shaping by the way it this doesn't match the
underlying reality and that the tactic here to win this is not
necessarily
like we can identify
that the Republican like policy platform seems to be out of touch
with I I feel like reality, right?
Like this. So, this poll also is a correlary. It's like if you
do not believe the Republican policy platform, the the things
they've implemented so far, if you think they're out of touch
with reality or the American way of life or whatever, then you'd
have to agree that this poll is like out of touch as well. And
so, it becomes a narrativization or a a uh like a marketing problem.
It is not an underlying position or or like yeah, it's just a
marketing problem. And I think we can identify that their marketing
solution was not appealing to the center, right? We would never
argue that Trump is appealing to the center and that's how he's
winning votes, right?
Like that's insane. That's an obviously insane thing
to argue that Donald Trump is winning by appealing to the center.
I hope we focus on independence. Focus on political. I I would
want to see that, right? I want to see what independents said
yes to this. Is that broken down in the in the larger study?
>> I imagine it. Hang on. Let me I can look up the article.
It's article that a lot of people off. >> Yeah, look that
up. I got to go to the bathroom real quick. I'll be right back.
>> 2 minutes and 10 seconds needs to go out. Uh Eve does
too. I got to walk them real quick. Also, Aaron, >> I got
to I got I got to actually take off too cuz I got to I got to
feed my pets and then get dinner going. >> Okay. Well,
>> so we can pick this up another time >> Yeah, we
can. Also, um Aaron said you had said in chat like asked her
to join the call. So, um she was ready, but if you didn't want
to if you want to do that another time, you can do that, too.
>> Aaron, if you're around tomorrow, I'll be live like
all day. So yeah. >> Okay. And you too. >> [__]
I should have I should have messaged like and just said, "Hey,
would Hutch talk to me?" "Hey, would Hutch would Hutch talk to
me? Could I talk to Hutch? Can I speak to Hutch?
Mr. Hutchinson? Could I talk to Mr. Hutchinson, please?" >> Me,
too. We can Yeah, we can all three. It's fine. >> I'll
be I'll be around. Um, but hey, I appreciate you calling in.
I just I just want to say because again, like I I hate the online
like Yeah. Like nothing I say, you know, 240 characters doesn't
convey. Like none of this is personal. Like none of this is like,
hey, I think you're a huge vile piece of [__] Nothing
I've seen anyway makes me feel that way. Um, this is just my
passion and and issue with uh what I think the impact is going
to be in the long run. And I I view these people in many ways
as ideological opponents, but I also view them as, you know,
there are people within my party, even if we don't go to the
far left, that I view as ideological opponents, such as that
are, you know, cheering on this goddamn war. like you know people
that are are going back to you know when when I think of the
leftist legit you know I've come to kind of understand what they
mean by that which is like all these people you know raging about
how they were against the Iraq war and all that stuff and suddenly
like you know we're going to do you know Iraq 2.0 in Iran and
>> I mean all that's valid just don't all that's valid
but stop I think it's bad when people say stuff like oh this
is obviously a false flag in Texas I think the conspiracy theory
is bad in this >> I have no idea that's something that
confuses the out of me like like I see that tweet from Hassan
that you're replying to and I have I I think by the way
I don't want anybody unless you criticized Loaderbox for his
take on the school girls. Okay, you don't get to criticize Han.
If we're just going to say that I don't like this regime and
they've lied before pretty consistently. Lots of notable lies.
So I'm going to call them a liar first before I believe anything.
We're going to if we're going to let that go, okay, we have to
let that go when Hassan does it, too. I personally I I appreciate
that world. Okay, cuz otherwise I have to like look into all
of this stuff before I just say this is a scop. I prefer the
world where I can yell this is a scop and never look into it.
Okay. No, I >> What was Lbox's takes? So, I just saw a
clip and maybe the clip is wrong. I saw a clip that was just
him saying like I don't trust Iran. I don't trust these Iranian
[__] They lie all the time. So, I have to I have
to wait.
And it's like, well, if that's going to be your first reaction,
then I think you could just go I I don't trust this. I think
you're lying.
Right.
I Okay. conspiracy you're talking about. >> Like it's not
there's nothing like implicit that I can see that's a conspiracy
theory in that. >> No. Okay. >> I'm not saying it's
not. I'm saying like I'm not seeing what you're talking >> You
have to be a bit of a lore master. It was just like yesterday
he tweeted out something to the effect. >> You you got
to really be following Hassan here. Okay.
>> It's not atrocity apology. It's him saying he would
wait, but it's him assuming a lie from the people reporting it
before they before he looks into it. Right. Like usually what
you would do is you would assume the truth and then work back
and see what's actually going on or just say you're neutral.
To assume a lie is a specific act, right? So I'm saying if we're
going to get mad at people assuming a lie then or sorry, if we're
not getting mad at people assuming a lie, then I'm totally fine
with that of oh it's obvious that America and Israel are going
to do a false flag terrorist attack to justify more military
action. And so that tweet where he went come on man that's he's
referring to that. So he's saying like this is too this is so
obvious that it's a false flag. I see and this is again like
I I don't know how many times I have to reiterate this >> Hassan
Hassan will always if there's like a if there is a thing that
happens that shapes narratives in a way that like benefits Israel
Hassan will automatically assume that that is a false flag that
is a explicit act by Israel to further some something they have
going on right he'll he'll make or or Israeli sympa sympathetic
people or it's being like framed disen disingenuously to support
Israel he'll always make those assumptions
that's baked in if you hate that if you absolutely hate that
and can't be around him or can't can't like conscion the guy
for that reason, then that's fine. But that's something he does
and it's like I'm I'm okay with it cuz I don't like I'll say
it's stupid. But I'm I understand why he does it. I understand
how he does it. It's just
like you just have to accept that or not or just say like I can't
I can't handle this guy because he thinks um he thinks that
you know Israel would do something nasty
to shape narratives on their behalf. If that's what you want
to say, >> I promise you that's it. Promise you from from
me coming from me. Like I don't know how many times I had to
say this. Like I have no, you know, love or admiration for Hassan,
but like I I see that and like knowing now that he tweeted that
yesterday or even without it. It's like come on, man. Like come
on, man. Really? Someone had to go do this with his shirt or
like this had to happen. Like it's not to me implicitly like
the conspiracy theory. It's like like really hell, dude. >> No,
that's not what he's saying. It's 100,000. He's saying that's
a false flag. That's what he's saying. Look through the replies.
>> All right, I'll >> look through the replies of
that post. I promise you. All right, I'll go take a >> Okay,
so we have I think I have a time stamp on this right now. Okay,
so we can do this. I think their conversation is about to end.
So this will probably end the segment right here. >> What
is this? I looked at this the other day and like cooks isn't
wrong. In the last week, while Hutch has been arguing with DG
about moderation and yelling, I saw in the news there was a mega
shooter at Mara Lago. Mexico attacked the cartel. The Clintons
testified at Congress. Zoron handled a historic blizzard and
right-wing yelled about snowgate. A massive consolidation of
huge news networks by Trump friendly was bought by Trump friendly
billionaires. Gavin News had a terrible book tour. Texted a huge
primary Dems showing up and Hutch has been talking about chat
moderation argument with DG calling him out and on us on hate
us on all you want but he's covered all of that while having
Obama's NASCA adviser on Roana to discuss Iran and North Carolina
rep candidate to discuss her campaign and AI. It's true. >> Oh
that
that's a very vital part of the coalition. Okay. He's just explain
he's just he's just dropping facts. Okay, he's just dropping
facts. Can't even can't even disagree with it. It's not It's
not attacking anybody. It's just stating facts.
Repeatedly stating facts over and over again. Okay. LBox just
wanted confirmation on what happened. I Well, he was assuming
a lie, right? He was assuming a lie. I'm saying if you if you
just say I I'm waiting on I'm waiting to see like more news on
this cuz I
uh Yeah, maybe. Either way, I'm like fine with it. I'm I'm fine
with basically saying these people lie. I don't trust I just
I just think God allowed that when the Israeli regime does it,
too. And then I think you have to actually look into the facts.
All right. So long as you actually look into the facts, you could
say, "Well, I don't I'm going to wait on this to come to a conclusion
cuz I don't trust these people." Right? That's totally fine.
>> I did do that. >> I just think I just think it
would be received very differently
if you said that about the IDF. Okay. I think a lot of people
would receive that very
What is this liykan
Alex Jones level of conspiracy theory nonsense is not a problem
exclusive MAGA and the right hey just curious are the next few
weeks/ months depending on the length of the conflict going to
be mostly dedicated to useless assign coverage or uh do you plan
to try to do something important on this issue what the l friend
if you don't like the stuff I follow post unfollow mute block
me that's a nice copout response
>> I hate I hate this cuz like I'm technically kind of
doing it as well I do think that Lykan has like a slightly different
point and it sucks. This is what leads to everybody being like
totally sidescooked is like Lyan having an opinion that's against
Asan and then or sorry against Hutch and then tweeting about
it like he will be used as a wedge that will be used as a wedge
by a bunch of people who cover this stuff and I sometimes I
half your chat is currently doing dockets for Hassan. Okay, well
let's chill on that. Don't don't
Come on, man. Come on, man. Don't point that out to people. Okay.
So, so I was just saying I think Leica gets used as wedge here
and it's it's unfortunate for Lykan because I don't think he
like on Twitter. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Sure. Sure. Sure. Sure. Sure.
Yeah. I know. I know what you're saying. I'm I'm joking. I'm
joking. It's substance. It's Matt. It's um
it's all these people. It's all of these people. I see the tweets.
I see them. Anyway, so nice copout response. So, yeah. I like
it being used as a wedge. is just if it makes me feel awkward
cuz I don't think Lyan's like looking to do that.
Um, no, no, no. I don't I don't know if he cares. I'm just saying
that like you understand that now when Lyken becomes this wedge,
he's going to be pushed into a position where DJs are going to
be super ass mad at him. And
like people in my community are going to be pushing on the other
side of that or people in Hassan's community be pushing on the
other side of that. and like it's like in the middle of it being
ground down which I just I feel it's rough because I see it happen
and I'm I'm used to it. Okay. It happens to me all the time.
I'm fine with it. All right. I' that's been my experience on
the internet the entire time I've been on the internet. Okay.
But it's it's I think some people think it's tough. Okay. He
was already pushed into a position for absolutely nothing. That's
true. That is true that he did nothing at all. That I guess here's
probably what Lykan's thinking. Actually, never mind. Here's
what Lykan's definitely thinking. Well, I already get used as
like a as a tool for this anyway. I already get like hate from
these people anyway. I might as well just say my
>> I might as well just do it, right? Cuz if I'm going
to get hated for being this guy even when I like barely speak
when I just show the e-collar that I use and everybody's going
to freak out about that like it's an insane defense of Hassan,
then I might as well just give my actual opinion. Yeah, I can
see it. >> It would be way more honest to say you like
the positive benefits it brings to your channels and you value
that more than meaningful substantive content. You're not saving
America by dunking on Assan to an audience that already hates
Assan.
Damn. Also, I'm not even wrong. Like, what am I supposed to say?
The timing of this is not suspicious. That's why I waited. That's
why I I would never say when I when I analyzed this, I kept that
cut out in my head. I'm like, "No, Hassan might definitely call
it Hassan would definitely call something a false flag without
thinking about it. If it was like
like sort of putting out a narrative that was favorable towards
Israel, he would definitely say that." So, I was like, I need
to see cuz that text doesn't show me it, but is there another
way I could like look at this? Is there another way I could look
at this and uh like see is there more information? It's like
um it's the Death Note scene. Okay, you know the Death Note scene
where L introduces the fake message to show that like Light was
basically acting with private information. It's like I I discerned
Okay, I didn't make the mistake L did. I discern, sorry, the
the mistake Light did. I I discerned that there was like another
play here, another there's a piece of information missing. Okay.
Actually, in the Death Note sense, the It's a fake piece of information,
but in this sense,
yeah, they say gods of death love apples. Yeah, exactly.
I I discerned it. Okay, we're operating at a higher level here.
I'm going to start playing the music for myself in two seconds.
Okay,
I got to stop sucking myself off because otherwise I'm going
to have to start playing the music for myself. And not good.
Not good. I literally tweeted yesterday, "If there's any terrorism
that happens on US soil now, you will never be able to convince
me nor millions of other Americans that it wasn't Israel and
America conducted get together to rally the masses to support
an insanely unpopular war." He did tweet that yesterday. >> Liberals
also love doing this. Wait, is that the tweet? Wait, is that
the tweet
is that the tweet
that leads you to believe that was a false flag? Cuz I don't
think those two things add up. I I intuited it because I just
assume Ham call something that that is like positive narratively
for Israel false flag before looking into it. I I just assume
that. But if if the tweet is what you're working off of to say,
well, this is what it means that that other comment is a false
flag comment. I don't think those add up. It's got to be a different
tweet, right? It can't be that's two days ago. It can't be that
tweet. >> They get together to rally the masses to support
an insanely unpopular war. Liberals also love doing this. And
it's just crazy when it comes to Muslims. It's like they forget
that this administration is the administration that literally
sent this out.
They are still pushing the narrative of someone wrote anti ice
on their bullets.
Oh, wait.
This was totally fake though.
Hold on. This was totally There's no reason to expect. Like,
why is there just an open magazine there? Why is there an open
like
right
and then they wrote it with pen on the side of it? Herm, that's
a clip. It is a clip, I guess. But this was totally like I think
this was totally fake actually.
Huh. You know,
like liberals forget that it's the same Trump administration
all of a sudden when it comes to when it comes to uh potentially
Muslims of the crosshairs or potentially like Israel first foreign
policy. The same liberals that were like, hm, very interesting
that this administration is doing a very bad like they're very
bad job creating domestic propaganda are turning around and and
going, no, this time it's real. This time it's definitely real.
Comx will collapse whether the derivatives market and they will
blame Iran war not comx
uh can these guys just speak American? The [__] happening?
What terrorist language are they speaking right now? That's a
joke. That's a joke. That's a
>> I was watching Bruce Green and Bruce was saying the
scalp is having a hard time on Twitter and Shadow said the Baldi
brings it on himself. I have no idea what that is. Iraqi Shi
group
posted a video of them launching rockets at the US Arabil base.
easily the most insane stuff from 2011 of the Arab Spring Ring
was Shia in Bahrain literally reignited now and far more besides
across the region and for >> Okay. Was that it? No more
stuff. We're done [laughter] with that. No, we're not done with
that. Okay. Okay. >> wait.
Why is he [clears throat] he's just laughing at that? What the
[__] Hold on. >> Reuters are saying the last
Iran strike Benjamin Netanyahu. Sorry, I'm trying to do the new
Hassan laugh. I guess the hiccup laugh. >> May Allah awaken
the people. >> Yeah, they hit Berlin. >> You see
the evil doings of
the United States. >> Please verify. [screaming]
>> Ted Cruz shredded was joking about dead soldiers on
the timeline. Wait, what?
It's not every day you see a US senator joking about dead US
Marines. Were your friends Germans wearing Nazi tattoos like
the I can assure you your praise didn't save my friends from
dying in the last war you supported
oh my >> oh Ted Cruz coming out against um special forces
and soldiers overall having questionable tattoos very interesting
very interesting Ted >> huh okay this is the end of the
hut stuff all right I think we're done with the hut stuff in
the video too um and yeah
I know I might read the sub stuff real quick >> yeah I
appreciate you coming on man I'll be on all day. Hit me up. >> All right,
brother. Have a good night.